they would do this thing at my pool
where they would have like how to learn
how to kayak like in the pool
yeah they would like people they would
put six kayaks in the pool and just let
people kayak around it and i don't know
how this happened
but after the kayak has left there was a
[ __ ] in the pool
now they're in kayaks how do they get in
the pool kids are [ __ ] weird man
kids are weird hello
and welcome to another episode of trash
taste i am your host for today
gant grant whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call me and with me as usual
is the boys the voice
it's really selfish of you to have that
name because it's really inconvenient
for me when i'm texting about you
it's just it keeps autocorrecting you
keep correcting it you know how
inconvenience that is to me god do you
know how inconvenient
it is when i it autocorrects my own name
when i'm referring to myself
it's even more inconvenient because when
you look up gant
on like wikipedia it goes to my [ __ ]
[ __ ] like
[ __ ] twin foil hat
i saw it on the subway it's like when
you look up geek it's like the anime man
what is gigguk's real name joey bazinga
i [ __ ] said it i've known you've
known each other
[ __ ] out so how are you doing boys
it's been a while
you guys don't know this but it's been
like a three week break yes we last
recorded
um through the magic of scheduling you
will
you wouldn't have had a break at all but
uh yeah it's been in three weeks since
we lost
yeah i've had a recovery i mean we had a
three-week break right because uh
well you went on journey across japan
across japan
abroad in a man
i also hung out with chris before that
in kyoto yeah it was like kind of like
an awkward timing where it was like
three weeks where we couldn't record
yeah but it's i don't know it's been a
nice refresh i'd say yeah came back i'm
sick of [ __ ] seeing you guys
yeah god every week jesus man
i mean it's it's uh it's because i think
normally especially when we did three
episodes in one week
because that's what we had to you know
allow us to do yeah on the last episode
i was like
like what are we talking about yeah
there's only so much i can chat [ __ ] you
know if you're chatting [ __ ]
every day for like three times a week
whatever and it's not like
we're all going out and doing like
interesting things every day right it's
like
five days out of the week we're just in
our room like just working on videos
yeah like that's that's what i mean we
talked about this earlier but like how
do
like streamers who stream every day and
just like what do they talk about
because sometimes when we have more than
one recording a week sometimes i'm like
i don't know what the [ __ ] to talk about
sometimes you know like what's going on
with you with you guys
i'm not i was like the barrel is very
shallow the
bottom is just there what's going when
you're playing games or you're playing
apex oh just just like last week like
the police don't stop me
i wanted to talk about it i need to
commit a crime to like
make a story i'm not running out
you got to be talking about the other
streams that happen yeah yeah yeah
just going to like watch youtube videos
really funny name last stream called pee
pee poo poo
it was a really fun moment let me drag
that up for 15 minutes
i mean it's like i don't know i don't
know how much i'm allowed to talk about
journey across japan because i think at
this point it's free probably no
christmas yeah
it's probably not even out yet but i
think the trailer will be out by then so
if you want to check that out i guess
here's a teaser joey won't say
everything that happened i'm sure
watch the videos yeah yeah just go watch
the videos whatever
i mean i mean yeah i literally came back
yesterday yeah as i was recording this
so
yeah how was it was it oh it's [ __ ]
insane like
hype it up hypothetically i'll hide it
up i'll hype it up all right i'll hype
it up for chris joney across japan too
uh i should probably explain what
unicorn so if you don't know
uh journey across japan is a series that
chris broad who's been on this show a
couple of times let me guess
you go across japan we go across japan
as i would say it kind of speaks for you
it's a show we do together on chris's
channel where we go across japan do like
challenges and like go visit cool places
in japan
and join across japan three is like the
third one we just finished where we went
through uh
kyushu which is like the most southern
island in japan right awesome because
i'd never been to kyushu like at all and
just this past week i
went through all the prefectures of
kyushu in one go so yeah [ __ ] great
speed running tourism yeah we were
speedrunning kyushu literally
i like how chris got took you around
like all the amazing places and he told
me like the shittest place
didn't you go to like a gin factory or
something we did go to a gym place yeah
was that like the highlight that was the
highlight yeah actually just got to
drink really nice gin that was like free
which is like
oh that's that's cool yeah and then you
could just be like make me this cocktail
and they made it which is great which is
like just a power trip that i needed in
my life
but uh but i mean you've already been to
kyodo all right yeah i've been once
before
um but he he found this welsh town like
welsh british town
in like an hour in like an hour in the
in the mountains in kyoto drive
wow and it was it was pretty [ __ ] but it
was pretty
good but it was just kind of like really
underwhelming was it just like home or
weirdly did you feel like culturally
culturally appropriated
in it i don't know it's just how people
like feel when they see white people
wearing kimono
this is kind of cool but like what's
going on like why i just wanted you to
be like oh god this is so [ __ ] just
reminds me of horror
it was just kind of like it was really
bizarre and like underwhelming i don't
know
but also the fish and chips is 22 which
is criminal i mean i'm sure like
i don't know how it feels like for say
like you know
someone who lived in china going to like
chinatown or something like that
i mean it's kind of different though
isn't it it's like markets and
restaurants right yeah that's i mean
that's true i feel like chinatown
okay it is actually china okay well what
describes me this welsh town then okay
so
that was what about a maid of welsh yeah
all the buildings looked like they were
just
pulled out of like a small town in wales
it was really weird
and it was just really old style like
the places where you'd find in like west
wales and it was just really strange
because it's like i did i didn't
particularly like everything written in
welsh or
well one of the pubs was called uh pond
oak and pond means bridge in welsh
oh okay at least they were accurate
about it that was pretty cool i think
the [ __ ] sheep
i'm really sarcastic about everything
and it was just like i feel like this is
the one time where i can be like
time to actually become sarcastic about
something and no one can correct me
this is my culture now welcome to my
culture
i mean it probably wasn't as offensive
as the first time i went to a [ __ ]
outback steakhouse right and i was like
whoa is this one australia's to everyone
yeah [ __ ] boomerangs on the wall
everywhere yeah just like an australian
home i don't really know i mean i i
i'm pretty i kind of bash on every
culture
but i'm by far the heart i buy far back
on my own culture more than anything
well that's good because
if it wasn't a culture yeah if i mean
anything else you'd be really bad
to say right now americans be like oh
really
[ __ ] vain i'm pretty harsh on
americans but
i feel like i'm more harsh on though i
mean i feel like that's just that's just
part of british culture right yeah
because you just
you rag on everyone equally but you
especially rag on your own culture oh
yeah of course um
but like for some reason when someone
else rags in your coach you're like no
only i get to complain about my culture
thank you very much
that's the one time everyone has a
patreon i feel like being british she
can't really complain anymore like
everyone everyone [ __ ] mocks proof
so you kind of just get used to it i'm
just like yes honey oh you made another
british meme bottle of water alright
yeah i mean i mean like i feel like
self-deprecation is just part of
british culture and british mentality
it's such an amazing
fall though right like especially on
youtube because like remember amazing
for
the rise and fall of british columbia
because remember in like 2015
everyone was [ __ ] obsessed with
british culture and now everyone's like
oh
in this english form of death i i think
it's just because
the internet has just realized what
british people actually sound like
it's just i always wondered that when i
was like growing up
no one sounds like this everyone in the
uk doesn't sound like harry styles
what and i'm and i'm just like what what
because i remember growing up i was like
when uh when i like the world when is
the world going to realize that
people don't sound like they do in harry
potter yeah every other like british
film like doctor who or whatever
i'm just waiting for the day that
everyone realizes that not everyone in
australia looks like chris hemsworth
debatable i mean i know like two people
and they look you know you're one of
them you look close enough
to chris hemsworth you're getting you
get ripped you're the licorice hamburger
now if i get ripped i look like jason
mama
what are you waiting for
okay tell me tell me what else you get
up to then in fukuoka
okay i can tease well i mean journey
across japan so there's always a theme
right so like the first journey across
japan was cycling yeah it was chris
cycling yeah and i was just on one part
of it
um but then the second journey across
japan i was there fully for it and uh
it was called escape to fuji so the
theme of it was we went around
mount fuji and like all the cool places
we can go to mount fuji because
chris had never seen a nice view of
mount fuji in his life so he's never
taken one of those like touristy photos
right and he kept like
apparently his audience kept sending him
like pictures of like
amazing views like hey look chris i was
here for two days and i got an amazing
view of foundation [ __ ] you
so you can check it out now by the way
yeah you can check it out now it's all
there so
the third journey across japan is called
the lost islands because
uh the kyushu area has all these like
it's kind of like jurassic park here man
yeah right even though like the [ __ ]
like promotional artwork
looks like a [ __ ] like shitty movie
poster like
like it's like i say shitty it looks
amazing but like
yeah so the uh the kyushu area is like
it's almost like
an archipelago of just these like insane
amount of
time was that word sorry archipelago
what the [ __ ] you whip someone needs to
whip out a dictionary
really you're looking for mailings you
can be on your side here okay all right
like something so like the philippines
for example is an archipelago because
it's just a bunch of
tiny tiny tiny islands so basically
cultural cross-pollination all over
again man
layman's terms there's lots of tiny tiny
islands
along the coast of kyushu yeah so we
were like oh that's perfect we'll call
it the lost islands because we'll try
and go to as many of these like small
islands and i think we ended up going to
like three or four of them
um i mean obviously we couldn't go to
all them because there's literally
thousands of them out there but some of
these islands were [ __ ] insane
looking like
completely awesome pictures yeah yeah i
showed pictures
yeah but um yeah it's just incredible
like we literally did
speed run kyushu yeah i think i think
because like that week felt like a month
yeah it was [ __ ] insane it sounds
like you did a [ __ ] ton from
how you were describing it to me
honestly the challenges that we like
usually you know prepare with on journey
across japan yeah this time around was
like kind of a back burner just because
there's so much [ __ ] we were doing
like oh yeah i forgot we had to do like
a challenge for this video [ __ ] yeah but
yeah hopefully the trailer will be out
by the time it goes out yeah
if chris isn't lazy yeah if not sorry
chris i probably just sent a bunch of
where's the trailer people over to your
channel
yeah what i want to know is that how
many more places can he do journey
across japan like how many more themes
can he do because like
one thing i will say about japan is that
one one thing one other thing that
impresses me the most is just
how [ __ ] varied japan is in terms of
like how many places there are to travel
when to explore right
and i'm just like because i'm used to
the uk right and i feel like if you've
explored
a decent amount of the uk then you've
kind of to me at least you've kind of
seen it all in one town
yeah yeah if you go you go to one town
you go to one city and it's it's kind of
all the same i mean london
to me london kind of exists in its own
bubble london's like unique but like
anywhere outside of london
i mean [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean yeah i mean australia is the same
thing right like i think geographically
it's
just as large as like the us maybe close
to it
yeah we have sand so it's like 80 of it
is a [ __ ] desert
so it's like that's why like i've barely
gone exploring in australia because i'm
just like i just don't know what there
is out there but then again
if chris hadn't like gone and done like
extensive research on places in kyushu
yeah i probably would have had no
[ __ ] i don't know how chris finds
these [ __ ] places no
he comes to me with this town in the
middle in the mountains of kyoto yeah
right
well how do you find this he literally
just like spends months just researching
like interesting places i remember like
on journey across japan too
there was this like in the middle of the
mountains in uh gifu prefecture or
toyama i think it was toyama prefecture
which usually you know people don't go
to for tourism
yeah he found this like in the middle of
the [ __ ] mountains there was this
like field of like
a thousand statues of people that had
just been built
and you know how he found it he
literally went on to like google
satellite and just like scanned through
the mountains oh my god what the heck
absolutely until he stopped and was like
what is this what is this gray bulb
and like enhanced enhanced and then i
saw that there were these statues and
because like if you look it up like
before that video went up there is no
articles about it like not even japanese
media talks about it
yeah this is like some next level this
is like some nasa [ __ ] yeah i was like i
want your like
dedication of research people do strange
things with their land in japan
like in the uk you just kind of have a
field and maybe put a fence in it yeah
let's call it a day but there's only so
many things you can do you know
apparently they seem to go crazy with it
they're like what if we just made
a field that's just trampoline outside
like all right dude if
i mean that's what's so awesome about
japan is that you can just be driving in
the middle of nowhere then
like you just see this weird like this
weird [ __ ] place that
you don't know who you don't know what
madman came up with this idea just put
like a [ __ ] like a like a field of
statues
like it's like it's not even like built
for tourism either because like it's not
even known
yeah yeah yeah it's like it's like if
you're lucky enough to find it then
there you go there it is enjoy it
i'm hoping the next journey across japan
is just like five star hotels and chris
is like come come come on connor let's
go
let's go just go review five star hotels
i'm down for that journey across
michelin restaurants
not only not only is it a tax deductible
it's also
fantastic it's fun i want to do this
yeah but please look forward to that
whenever that i think he said it's
coming out end of
may maybe so hopefully soon so like how
many more places in japan do
you want to visit personally so i have
this app actually on my phone
where you can keep track of it's it's
what i use to keep track of all the
prefectures i've been to google
it's called google maps it stalks you it
knows exactly
okay yeah so like have we told the story
about the cycling yeah
uh yeah okay i mean so i i know
because i i like this that google tells
me exactly where i was for how long
yeah i like looking back where i was and
like because when people ask me oh where
were you this day i'm like oh let me
check
yes
but like it tells you exactly where you
were for how long yeah and when we did
the cycling special we all had our phone
tracking on that wasn't sharing the
video but we actually saw where we all
were
yeah throughout the video yeah and uh
when the video was done uh i asked them
i was like hey guys can you export your
map data so that we can send it to our
editor so that he can
know where we were so that's how you see
all the you know cool map
graphics that i made 100 accurate but
it's pretty close it's pretty close
it's pretty close so where we are
generally on that map is actually so
we turned on location services which i
didn't know that you could track each
other
like in like light in like real time so
so it wasn't a part of like the big
we didn't make it a big part of the
special but we could actually see where
we were as we were cycling down so we
could
i could see like that joey was [ __ ]
kicking my ass and
connor turned off his location sharing
when he was taking the ferry so he just
like
he just like popped out of existence i
literally thought
i literally thought he was like lost out
there yeah i just said i was probably
like he's dead he's just straight up
dead yeah so there was no signal
exactly when i asked these guys to share
it they were like wait
gantt was like wait what like they keep
all this information on here yeah
yeah it's awesome it's terrifying yeah
so so i i didn't realize
that um by turning on location services
i could go through my
entire history day by day and if you've
turned on location services
you can probably do that right now if
you go to google maps and and
you can go through the history of your
like location services
and it will tell you the exact location
you've been
hour by hour yeah every single day for
like the past 10 years of your life yeah
it's pretty good
that's it's scary that's terrifying
google is google is literally stalking
you
at all times you know what you're sad is
like when i used to live in london
because i barely ever left my house it
would be like what did i do this day
it's like a dot on the map of me not
leaving my house i'd be like oh what do
like i didn't know this is like some
[ __ ] fbi [ __ ] man
yeah i don't know like because sometimes
i go to a place and i'm like
[ __ ] where was that i could just go on
google and find out where i was i mean
it's cool
like you know to look back on right yeah
no it's it's you're the only one looking
at it
i mean i mean i mean it's like two sides
right because it's cool to know that you
could go through your entire life
history
but it's also kind of like i guess scary
or not not scary but like
disturbing that yeah your entire life
is like can be compressed down into a
file and just like analyzed right
and exported right and exported i don't
know that that's just that's just like
this this is the future that black
mirror like warned us about you know
that is some joy
i i for one welcome our black mirror
i welcome technology i don't know i
uh yeah i i don't know i like it it's
fun it's yeah it's
interactive it's right what do you what
do you mean interactive
it's not stalking it's interactive no no
i can see the cool side of it it's just
it just you know it's just a bit like
wait why did this come up again
because you're asking how many prefix oh
yeah so so is there any place there
so i have i have an app that shows me
all the prefectures i've been to and i
can
kind of give points as well it's been
like so it's like i visited there i
walked there i stayed there overnight i
lived there etcetera and like
adds on the point i lived here i did it
so i can i know exactly now like which
uh you know prefectures i haven't been
to yet um and i think
i mean i can bring it up but i think
maybe i've done
i want to say like three fifths maybe
three quarters of all the prefectures
but yeah these these are the ones i've
done red ones you've been to holy [ __ ]
so the red ones i've stayed overnight
i'll send this image to you but the red
ones i've stayed overnight the green
ones
i've like just stopped over the yellow
ones i've passed through the blue ones
i've
uh like walked around and the white ones
i haven't visited yet so
okay there's a decent amount that i
still haven't gone to but this is good
right because now
i can use that app basically to be like
all right well you know i want to like
take a weekend off somewhere yeah you
know like i can plan my next vacation to
be like well i've never been to this
prefecture yeah so let's go check that
out
yeah i wish i wasn't so [ __ ] stupid
man i just
don't really care where i am unless
there's like i don't know something fun
to do there i'm like oh yeah
of course yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't go
to a [ __ ] prefecture if i didn't have
anything to do there yeah
i'm not i'm not the type of guy who just
like okay i haven't been to this map yet
i haven't
been to this part of the map i need to
know that there's something cool to do
there
see this is my this is my jrpg like a
hundred percent completionist
coming out because i'm like i gotta i
gotta finish all 47 prefectures like
completed for me like it's like a
catch-22 because i want to go to new
places i want to find new cool places
yeah but i also
don't have the energy that chris does to
just like [ __ ] scout out places that
look like yeah
not only scour but like schedule it yeah
yeah like
meticulously it's like going with
someone who plans stuff i'm like yeah
you plan it i'll i'll i'll just
i'll come along i'll crack a few jokes
that's what i love across japan right
it's like it's a [ __ ] vacation for me
right honestly i have to be on camera
and talk for a few hours a day
that is definitely the benefit of
hanging out with chris he just takes
care of everything
yeah i know where we going i know a
place let's do it here's the definition
of i know a place
one time i i did that for chris i was
like i'll let me take you to a place
right we're in kyoto right and i was
like no
i know a great coffee place literally
outside where we were staying there's a
blue bottle coffee
right it's like the least kyoto thing
ever
like an american chain like that it's
good it's good it's good
that's too fat it's pretty [ __ ] good
it
this is japanese starbucks
starbucks do we have a clip name
japan's coffee is bottom tier because
probably not well we do now yeah we do
now
we talked about japan's coffee [ __ ]
it's
yeah i didn't know that i cared about
coffee until i moved to japan and i
realized that the coffee here was [ __ ]
because i thought living in england my
i'm not i'm just like whatever i
would [ __ ] i thought i thought like
my coffee tolerance was
i'll [ __ ] take instant coffee if i
need to but yeah like when i moved to
japan i've realized
what [ __ ] coffee tastes like but then i
got a job
and now i know so because remember the
the [ __ ] like
just the brainwashing that happens the
first time you come to japan you're like
i can buy a hot coffee at a vending
machine oh my god i'm going to play this
every [ __ ] day oh my god
then you realize it's just all sugar
yeah you realize it's all crap
yeah like oh starbucks has never been so
[ __ ] attractive to me so yeah so yeah
as you know as you know japan has like a
[ __ ] ton of vending machines like
everywhere yeah and i remember whenever
i used to go on holiday in japan
i'd always get the coffee uh vending
machine coffee every single day
without without fail and i'm just like i
will never get bored of this at all this
is [ __ ] amazing
i don't need to i don't need to go to a
[ __ ] starbucks or a coffee shop to
get my coffee
i can just go to a vending machine and
then i moved here and then i don't know
what it is about moving here like
something switched in my brain right and
then i just instantly recognized it
as like oh this tastes like crap this is
this is processed instant coffee [ __ ]
and i don't know i don't know why i
don't know what switched my brain like
why is it that when i was here as a
tourist i was
vending machine coffee and vending
machine drinks were just like [ __ ]
like five stars we don't have in the uk
so you're like you're
like amazed it's just like a new weird
thing right like you know conor i
remember was talking about how
you know every time every time you came
here to visit you would [ __ ] eat
you know family mode on geary every day
right yeah yeah and then you realized
oh this is not that great actually i've
actually gone back
on it now oh really i've got i've talked
about like a drone yeah
but i've been like full circle i've i've
relapsed
i was very diehard sandwiches for like a
year and a half and now i'm like man i
coffee is as much of like a smell thing
as it is a drink thing
like i need the reason why i like going
into a coffee shop
is because i need that that wall of
coffee smells yeah
that's what makes me feel like i'm ready
to [ __ ] drink i i'd say i
coffee is a [ __ ] morning thing for me
right now because
not a morning a [ __ ] morning it is a
[ __ ] moment because
honestly honestly is your morning really
started if you don't have a coffee
because to me
if i don't have a coffee that's like
that's like my indicator that my morning
has begun
i can begin the day if i don't have the
coffee then i'm just like in permanent
like
50 brain modes no coffee i sleep coffee
exactly that's literally how i am i
don't know i don't know if it's a
placebo thing no
i'm i'm totally the same like like i
remember there was one week where i was
like
i might be a little too dependent on
coffee let me let me let me back it up a
bit
yeah because i was having like you know
two three cups of coffee a day right so
i was like like
four or five yeah right and i'm like
that's probably not that good for me my
heart's probably about to explode so let
me like let me just go a week
with no coffee and see how i do day two
i was like
i was getting just insane migraines in
my head i was like oh
like i'm really [ __ ] dependent on
this [ __ ] to start the day i just get
sluggish if i stop
i don't really get too bad you don't get
like coffee headaches no i've never
gotten that
i feel like friends who got it how it
feels for me is that you know that
scene in the film where it's like it's
like like they got the grayscale filter
on it
that's how i see the world before i have
my coffee man and then
like i have the coffee and then like
they they instantly turn up the
saturation
that that is that is how my mornings
work i go from grayscale to sepia
the [ __ ] meme of uh don't talk to me
until i've had my coffee
like you're literally that guy no
because i remember when i first moved to
japan
and i my mornings were just like so
depressing because i didn't have that
first
that first good hot coffee to look
forward to right right
because even if i'd go to my like family
mart to get a coffee it was like really
watered down coffee wasn't it
i don't know it's it's i've noticed the
more i like
the more i like grow up it's the little
things in life that you need to look
forward to i don't know
it is a little things like my mornings
are 20
less happy if i don't have a coffee to
look forward to yeah i just feel like my
day is depressing that's kind of about
it really yeah yeah exactly that's like
most days
one time i went to an italian restaurant
here and you know i feel like an italian
restaurant
i feel like you can almost judge it on
uh how good their espresso is with the
meal oh yeah
it must end on an espresso i feel at
least like you know yeah absolutely and
uh
you know it was good it was pretty good
food i was like not bad have you have
you found one that has a good espresso
because i've
yet to find one there's one or two that
you know if i see the the
actual espresso machine in the back i'm
like nice yeah you know it's going to be
good because they've
they've gone to the effort to get this
ridiculously expensive machine
just for this like one part of yeah
right right yeah um
but i i was i was eating there and the
food was pretty good you know i was
disappointed and i thought well
fantastic i'm going to end my meal off
with an espresso and it said on the menu
he said espresso
right it was a double or a single and so
i ordered the double espresso
and they they just brought out
essentially an americano
what and i said i said like oh no no i
ordered the espresso like i don't know
that's the espresso and i'm like what
it's like this this talk i'm like that's
not an espresso and if it is i'm going
to be having a heart attack
it's like a triple double espresso i'm
like what am i the [ __ ] here
are you going to make me pay for this
i'm not paying for this
i paid for it but you know i didn't walk
out
and naturally i didn't complain and i
paid for it but that's not the point i
mean i was very disappointed was that at
least a good americana no he's awful
that day onwards i i swore against
ordering coffee in places where i
couldn't visibly see an espresso machine
in the establishment i'm like timing to
the back take me to the back let's see
what's going on come on
yeah because i i'd say like the best
purchase i've made in japan
bar none is the nespresso machine i'm
gonna get that soon
i would trade my first born son for an
espresso machine honestly straight up
like i
that thing i i hug that thing yeah every
day
give it a morning kiss i could go
homeless and the one thing i'd keep with
me is the inspiration
i'd be going around on the street
holding the espresso machine plugging
into outlets when i can
just to get a coffee this episode of
trash taste is sponsored by
honey we'll shop online and we've all
seen that promo code field taunters at
the checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupons is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your card
and honey supports over 30 000 online
stores
that's a lot of stores it's more than i
can count alright here's how it works
gentlemen break it down imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite sites
when you're at the checkout the honey
button drops down and all you have to do
is click
apply coupon that's so simple wait a few
seconds there's honey searches for
coupons it can find for that site and if
honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the price drop that's it it's a
simple
that's it that's gentlemen gentlemen
trade offer you get savings you get free
app
i get i get honey tell me gentlemen what
have you saved on honey
recently gone i bought some gym clothes
that i saved about ten dollars on
and i haven't used them yet and i
probably won't be using them because
it's summer and i'm not gonna go outside
but at least you saved something
at least you know at least i saved some
money guys q credits honey has found
it's over 17 million members over
two billion dollars in savings what are
you waiting for if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing on free
savings it's literally free to install
and it only takes a few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a favor and also supporting
us i'd never recommend something i don't
use get honey for free at joinhoney.com
trash taste that's join honey.com
trash taste back to the episode yeah
speaking of coffee machines i uh
i found this [ __ ] so like aki's quite
obsessed with tick-tock
okay as as most people are okay these
days yeah
like i don't have like because i don't
have tick-tock install on my phone right
my only exposure to tick-tock is aki
yeah
and uh and this [ __ ] thing where
you know those like [ __ ] tick tocks
where it's like amazon gadgets that
changed my life part 71 like you know
those
[ __ ] they all sound the [ __ ] same
there was one where it was literally
this
alarm clock all right it's 400 bucks it
was this alarm clock
that makes you a cup of coffee oh we had
when it went
yeah we had that in the like 80s in the
uk for tea really yeah it was called a
kettle mate
and uh could set the alarm and it would
pour a cup of tea for you
this is this is not a new invention tick
tock [ __ ] yeah so it's like it was like
there's like a [ __ ]
it looks like maybe it's about that big
that's pretty massive it's pretty
[ __ ] large but there's like you know
the
the cup the coffee mug there and then
there's like a proper brewing thing
on the side and you put in this like
canister of milk in the morning
right like lock it in and when the alarm
goes off it just straight up just makes
you a [ __ ] like
an espresso machine is literally one
button you could literally have that
next to your bed
you don't need it yeah exactly that's
what i was thinking i was like
just get a [ __ ] nespresso machine and
just put the [ __ ] thing in and
do it yeah so please just sponsor us
already yeah like
like like cause the problem is right i
feel like nespresso
is one of the best capsule machines but
i feel like in japan it's the only
capsule machine
it's actually good because the like you
could get like the actual
uh you know the ones actually you have
to put the uh the coffee um
grinded the beans right yeah but like i
had one of those
i had one of those as well cleaning it
is such a it's a bit of an effect yeah
yeah
like nespresso is like the perfect i'm
literally just [ __ ] marketing to you
right now yeah it is literally the
easiest
and like easiest to clean it's just easy
for the quality you get and for the
convenience it is
the best capsule machine please
sponsored
a lot of capsule machines
we bought one just for this office it
was literally the first purchase that we
made
and we tried to get geeks plus to play
for it for us but they wouldn't allow it
so we played before we bought this table
we bought the nespresso machine
we had our priorities right that's for
sure exactly yeah i remember when they
gave us the spreadsheet of just like
okay
so they get so geeks gave us a
spreadsheet because they said they would
help
us um dick not decorate the office but
refurbish the office yeah and we were
like okay
tables desk television um not my story
no but there was a it was it was split
up in like here's the list of uh
like here's the list of the things we
need and here's the list of the things
we want and we put
the espresso machine in the first thing
on need
we're like no no you know what i'm
saying yeah we need this
do you really need this is this as
necessary
as the table and we were like yes yes
without without coffee this podcast is
not happening no i'm sorry
i'm not i'm not going to film yeah i
refuse to release episodes
because like another thing about
japanese like coffee shops as well is
that there are so many
independent coffee shops here in japan
so if you ever come to japan you you can
walk down a random street and find like
five to ten different like indie coffee
shops and the problem is they all look
[ __ ] great yeah they do but it's such
a coin flip
on whether it's going to be good coffee
or not because
the the like the fallacy is that you
know it's i've
like some of the best and poshes looking
coffee shops i've been to in japan
have just had the shittest coffee yeah
it's like acid yeah
it's like dirt water like because i
remember like uh especially in like
central tokyo like nishiazabu
and like um stuff like that there's like
a lot of like
really like fancy kind of like rustic
looking coffee shops where
the beans are all lined up and they got
like they got the aesthetic down they
got the aesthetic to a tea yeah
and then you order it and you're like
waiting for this cup of coffee for like
20 minutes
like what are they picking the [ __ ]
coffee beans off the plant like it's
taking
so long and what comes out is like [ __ ]
yeah and essentially it's it's just like
dirt water sometimes because
it's like twelve dollars please yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] twelve dollars for
like this one yeah i i thought like
because especially going to america or
something you order like a cup of coffee
and you just assume that it's refillable
right
it's that kind of level of quality but
in japan you can have like
the [ __ ] like instant coffee dirt
water
and they give it to you in this like the
poshest little cup and it's [ __ ] tiny
it's
dollars and you're just there being like
i'm even more depressed than i was
before i ordered this coffee that's why
it's sad right it's sad that like blue
bottle coffee and starbucks are like the
best coffee in japan
it really is it's like going to you know
any foreign country like you know
mcdonald's is the finest cuisine yeah
he's
literally the best like don't eat
anything like it's so sad
the foreigners did it better than you
yeah and they're [ __ ] chains
just like oh you want you want some good
fried chicken well
i know a place yeah it begins with a k
yeah
it's kind of it's got my favorite kernel
in front of it
it feels like you've like you're
admitting defeat where like the big
corporation's
the best at something yeah yeah all
right but like that's that's what i mean
when i say like we truly do live in a
tea society because yeah
like like they'll they'll do green tea
is amazing
here is [ __ ] great like the green tea
is obviously but like the other types of
tea here
[ __ ] fantastic but they just it's
taking a little bit longer to perfect
the coffee
i feel i i although i will say there's
some teas here with a like yeah it's
it's like cherry flavor and i'm like i
do not taste any tea in this this is
just cherry
are they like sweet teas well i can't
taste the tea and i'm like what's the
point in this see i'm i'm just
not a tea drinker so yeah i only drink
tea when i have afternoon tea
i don't know like i i don't i don't
drink tea
i i guess japanese tea is different
right because uh yeah
when i think of tea i think of hot tea
yeah i think i like an earl grey or like
a
english breakfast and yeah yeah stuff
right but like yeah i don't count green
tea is like a
like an afternoon tea tea i think
afternoon tea is probably the only good
british export that we've done it's it's
a british export that i'm proud of yeah
i'm like yeah is it really nothing else
a part of me dies inside whenever i go
to like a like a restaurant that does
like
foreign like european cuisine and i see
[ __ ] fish and chips there
i'm just like why are you selling fish
the best fish and chips though i ever
had
was uh this british pop british irish
pub called hobgoblin in shibuya
like maybe ever it's the best fishing
trip no no in japan
obviously no yeah in japan because every
other fish and chips i've had is like
they vinegar the [ __ ] out of the fish
where it's just like i'm not eating fish
i'm eating something
they should let you put the vinegar on
yourself yeah yeah but right but like
there's places where they just like do
it for it's [ __ ] up that's not right
yeah
so like the vinegar is like into in
inside the [ __ ] like
meat of the fish and i'm just like this
does not taste like fish it tastes like
vinegar
yeah like as much as i love vinegar
don't get me wrong what's the max from
you to pay for fish and chips
abroad or in england that's just a full
stop oh it's still still i mean how big
are we talking like
a normal portion like a normal port like
that that's why i was like you know when
i went to this place 15
no that's the most that's what i mean
right you would they charged me 22
i'm still angry about this by the way
they they're they're the same way you
made 22 dollars for a fish and chips 22
and it was mid [ __ ] honestly it was not
very was that at the welsh place yeah it
was at the wash tower
i'm sorry i feel like i'm like
completely ruining their like any
foreign tourism they get now but
that was like that fish and chips is
important and they increased the price
town reviewed by a welshman it was i
just i'm still annoyed about it
22 times 22 bucks are pretty ridiculous
my mom was she probably slapped me if
she saw that i've had money for that it
was
it was like a five pound fish and chips
as well it's not my chip was it like a
[ __ ] frozen iceland fish and chips
it wasn't good it was it was like more
batter than fish ah that's that's that's
what i've noticed whenever whenever i've
tried
tried fish and chips that have not been
from england of course even even in
england not every fish and chips you get
is [ __ ] good
[ __ ] like i'd say 80 percent of fish and
chips you get in england is [ __ ] anyway
why would i trust it outside of england
that's right you gotta go to a nice pub
a nice fancy kind of pub that does like
focuses on food a lot and they'll have
fish and chips on the menu it'll
probably be [ __ ] banging they might
have like
triple deep fried fries as well honestly
i want to take you guys to the hobgoblin
because
it's like a proper barramundi like
fishing i mean like the best fish and
chips i've had
is in brighton and it's like the one you
took us to
bankers i believe so i can't remember
probably
probably yeah they live next to a
[ __ ] ocean
next to the [ __ ] sea right so that's
that's like it's good fish and chips
because the fish is just fresh and you
can taste this fresh and it's like yeah
the one you took us to in brian was
easily the best fish and chips i've ever
had
but like like even so like there's
something that's i
i feel weird when whenever like you know
you go to japan and people like yo
you can try the ramen you can try the
sushi you can try all these different
cuisines
and someone visits me in [ __ ] england
and i'm like yo you want to get sir
you want to get some fish and chips go
to the local shipping go to a pub and
i'm just like
that's what you're going wrong you
immediately have to get them drunk
so that they can't so they don't focus
on they can't judge yeah
that's what i do i'm like let's go to
the pub right away like yeah yeah but
four people's in you won't kill each
other but like like the problem is when
they stay
they're saying for like a week right
because you're just like how many days
in a row can they drink alcohol before
they've realized i'm going to blow your
mind with the test community before
before they realize that there's just
not much to our culture that we can show
off to like
tourists that visit us that's what i
think i mean it's the same problem in
australia as well like
after you have a kangaroo steak there's
literally nothing else
it's like we have fish and chips as well
but like not as good
yeah because i i think the the one thing
i've realized
after moving japan after moving outside
of england and you know living in places
like thailand and
japan and stuff like that is that um
there's
to me in england there's not much to do
apart from drink
right if you don't drink is that what
happens when you live in a place or is
that what happens when you like
like leave it and are aware like i
wonder okay do you think do you know
what there's much to do
like is there much to do in australia
that you know of other than going to the
pub and going to the beach not really
far it's depressing at least we have
really nice [ __ ] beaches yeah at
least
at least you got that we don't even have
nice beaches like i am from
there my beach is very nice there's
plenty of free needles and
trash and everything like i say i tell
people i'm from i like i grew up in a
beach town a beach city yeah
it's bright it's bright and [ __ ] yeah we
have pebble we we like brighton
is the tourist beach in england right
and it's like the worst beach it's
pretty bad
and i say that as someone who grew up in
brighton i'm born and bred in bryce and
i'm just like it's
just a bunch of [ __ ] rocks you can't
even go there barefooted right
and to make matters worse brighton is
just as expensive as london so like
what's the point
of like it didn't always it wasn't
always like that you're like
i remember gentrified my i remember a
time when bryson was cheap
you know the the way you could tell this
is like this i don't know if this is
scientifically proven but i'm
as far as i'm concerned it is you can
tell the costs of a town in the uk
100 just go to the pub see what the the
pint of the beer the how much the beer
is
yeah if you if you see yeah go go one
point
if how much is like the the middle of
the like price
like pint yeah which is right right
because in brighton it's like what like
four pound fifty maybe five pounds
four pound five it's like london prices
that's on the expensive and where i'm
from it's like two pound twenty yeah oh
[ __ ] i i i i i
talk to people though that are from the
north or from wales or something and
they
tell me about these magical prices these
magical two mythical prices these
magical two pound prices
these are magical these are magical two
pound pints and i'm just like
what land are you from sir are you sure
that's are you sure it's beer that
you're drinking this
i'm sorry i didn't know we also i'm
sorry i didn't know you grew up in
[ __ ] narnia
what is this magical land that does not
exist in england it doesn't exist
also there are two americans as well uh
like a pint
is uh not an american point it's
different to the american point which is
also american pine's the biggest scam
ever by the way you guys got ripped off
i don't know why when americans took the
pint from us for some reason they made
it smaller
we talked about this on the stream
didn't did we oh okay yeah it's like
it's like a hundred milliliters less
you're losing a lot of beer there for no
point the one time when americans took
something and made us
it's like it's like 430 milliliters i
think around that in america and
british pine is 568 milliliters yeah
yeah and
uh yeah you get a lot of beer for like
really cheap it's like the
pint where i grew up is like four
dollars [ __ ] the point where i grew up
was nine dollars
that's uh you uh australian australian
well that's not like real money
it's nine dollar dues so usd it's like
seven dollars
that's about london prices then yeah
it's probably about london prices yeah
yeah i mean like i i feel like
it's growing up in the south in england
whenever i travel like further north and
i see
the prices it's just like i i i feel
i feel great because no matter where i
go in england i'm paying either the same
amount or
less or less than i'm used to this is
how like i i this is why
probably swiss people feel like the most
superior people on earth because
everywhere they go it's just like on
sale
like everything everything's cheap you
know what i mean that's why australians
love coming to you yeah
i feel so rich what do you mean it's
only one dollar for water
yeah exactly well i mean like remember i
found that [ __ ] izakaya
in shibuya where on i think tuesdays
it's not even a happy hour but like all
night it's 50 yen beers
that's but like when you go to places
like that the beer scent doesn't taste
right
i don't know if it's because i don't
know if it's like the psychological
effect of me thinking this is too good
to be trying
but i find when the beer is mega cheap
at these places in japan it tastes like
water
yeah but after 10 of them you don't care
yeah i mean
like for me i remember going back to
when we came here as a tourist i'm just
like
i'm gonna go to these like [ __ ] cheap
izakayas every [ __ ] day i'm gonna
i'm gonna take advantage of this drink
oh my god like nami hodai or you can
like all you can drink [ __ ] every
weekend yeah he's like
let's go guys and now i'm just like ah
and then corona was like no no no no no
but also
you're living here you just you just
feel like you kind of there's so many
other cool bars and other cool places
you can go to exactly that's
izakaya just feels like yeah i also
rarely drink to get like drunk any
anymore right i like i feel like that's
like
i normally get to the tipsy point i'm
like right i'm done yeah yeah yeah
exactly
it's also like i don't i want to be able
to function the next day
i'm okay we're too busy yeah basically
no because now now i
now i see nomiodae and i'm just like ah
well
i could drink as much as i want but you
know
do i need to anymore and then there's
always the thing of like all right i've
been drinking beer all night but i
really want to swap to like spirits and
uh
i remember the first time i went to an
izakaya and they were like would you
like uh just tamping like just
one by one or do you want me holiday and
the part where i was like uh i think
i'll just go tamping tonight
somewhere inside my head i was like
you've changed
how dare you what happened to you man
you used to be cool
like if you were asked no me hold it not
even a moment of your hesitation you'd
be like of course not me horde
yeah like i i i had the exact same
moment as well when i'm just like i
remember thinking to myself if
whenever i moved to japan i'm never not
going to say no
wait i'm going me say no to all you can
drink beers i
really and now i'm just like really all
you can drink i forget your thirty gone
[ __ ] man
i feel like i'm gonna be so much worse
than you at 30. i'm gonna be like
[ __ ] awful to hang out with
is it true that like your entire view on
everything just changes the moment you
hit 30 because that's all i've been
hearing
is it true you become a [ __ ]
i've heard from so many people who are
now in their 30s where like
it's literally i don't know if i
identify as a 30 year old yeah
i don't know if it's like placebo or
whatever the way you just like overthink
it but like
so many people are like yeah the moment
i hit 30. it's just like everything like
i just stopped giving a [ __ ] about so
much when i feel 30.
i i i'm the opposite i don't feel 30 at
all honestly i i don't feel like i've
changed
my [ __ ] i just i wonder how you can do
like
like i don't know i feel like i'm
struggling to keep up sometimes when
people want to party and i'm
you know i'm all right final cut no i'm
right there as well and i'm like well
i'll force myself to drink but half the
time i'm like my heart's not in it you
know
yeah my heart's not there you know i'm
still up there like guardians of life
god i'm i'm like always in bed by like
three now and gant would be like yeah i
stayed up until 9 00 am and i started
just doing work
it's like 11 30.
so he's napping in the carriage yeah i'm
like 60 yeah
that's a sad life yeah i don't know like
um i don't feel like i've changed
at all i'm almost 31 now and i feel like
i just
like i i feel like i'm i feel like i'm
still [ __ ] 25 23
i mean you still look 25 you're gonna be
you're gonna be like the [ __ ] old
anime character that's like the most fun
to hang out with
and he teaches you some cool [ __ ] and
then he sacrifices himself casually
later on he's gonna be the old man who
like looks really small but the moment
he takes his shirt off it's jacked
that's right basically
i mean i mean from what i've heard from
just other people who are older than me
they just told me that
third your 30s is just basically your
20s with one debuff to your body
and i i i i i i guess my hand is
what's the debuff for you i guess my
hangovers are slightly worse now that's
that's the only reason like
the only reason like i've i drink a [ __ ]
ton more wine now because i don't know
what it is
like it's funny right because when i was
when i was like eighteen
thirty you go you're like beer vodka nah
me moment you turn 30 i have a wine
cooler yeah and it's fully
you know that was exactly me when i was
30.
yes i only drink wine now thank you very
much beer
get get that teenage [ __ ] out the next
step is going to be like wine
cognac
yeah i don't know like i just i mean i
drink wine because one i like the taste
and two because
for some reason the hangovers for wine
are just like
seriously terrible i was like i remember
because like yeah exactly like when i
was in my teens in like early twenties i
was like
why and [ __ ] you i would get the worst
hangovers and wine especially
red wine like i swear i had like [ __ ]
vietnam flashbacks from drinking red
wine at university right thai man
like the hangovers there were like
[ __ ] unbearable and then i hit like
27 and i'm like oh this uh this this
this kind of feels warm
i don't even have those like nam
flashbacks because like i didn't even
like
i didn't even drink water making that a
thing
i didn't because i didn't even i wasn't
even interested in drinking wine i i
like you know in my early 20s because my
dad is like a [ __ ] heavy wine drinker
so he's always like you know try this
nice red wine
yeah of course australia yeah they all
love their wine
loads of wine yeah absolutely this is a
great wine now you know now that i can
drink wine it's like oh yeah that's
[ __ ] fantastic but
you know when you're like 21 22 and you
drink a glass of red you're like oh god
like i cannot
get used to this at all maybe we'd drink
more wine if we grew it in the uk but
unfortunately i think the only place
they make wine in uk are prison so i
don't really think that much choice
i think uk does make some wine is that
wine is that considered wine or is that
just like grape juice
attitude
as well you just get it from france
right so like why did you make your own
when everyone's gonna be like
we literally have friends like yeah
exactly and i didn't realize how
lucky i had it until i moved to a
country that you know is not well
i mean they produce sake here they do
produce wine but it's not as well known
i didn't know how good we had it there
where you can just go to a [ __ ] local
co-op or tesco's in the bike
great wine that is like tripled the
price here in japan
yeah yeah yeah and yeah sucks here yeah
that's the problem right
you have to go to like a specialist wine
place because like if you go to [ __ ]
family mart or seven it's it's like
you're just basically picking
poison if you drink a cheap wine here
you know it's it's basically just
it's basically just bottled rap boys
we have such first world problems
we're just like concerned about the
quality of the wine
listen what happened to us man i don't
know man well i didn't it's
i i would say i'd start drinking way
more wine because of um because of
corona
and because you know when you're stuck
inside you you gotta fight you gotta
find an interesting
decided to take up a new hobby
alcoholism
no but like it's incredible because like
i
it's the first time ever where i drank
something like a heavy heavy amount
yeah and i wake up the next morning i'm
like i i'm alive
now that see that's the thing right is
that i feel like that's a one-off right
i feel like that's being shot and it
like misses a vital organ that's what i
when you're no no no no no no no no it's
not a wonderful time for me for me like
if i just stay on wine and i just it i
don't mix drinks yeah wine hangovers are
the most bearable
like for me it's like beer is like
always worth stomachaches
always the worst headaches suck it's
like like hangover tianist okay
kangaroo jealous hang over here listen
let's go okay so
right at the top i don't [ __ ] with this
at all suck it okay yeah
like yeah like so where are we always is
s t here this
the strongest here is like the [ __ ] like
the worst hangover or shall we do the
opposite
like okay it should be it should be the
opposite okay okay well sake
is like [ __ ] zed tier okay like i
remember
like when uh when chris was last on this
podcast and we went to the
it's like just like just like one shot
of snack enough to give me a hangover
yeah like
i had if i'm drinking something else but
sake has even
entered my body words yeah it completely
contaminates me oh yeah yeah yeah it's
like
[ __ ] you connor yeah i remember we went
to the izakaya like
literally the hour afterwards and i was
on beer the entire night and then chris
was just like
let's let's get some sake right lads and
we had i had i remember having
like one cup of sake and then i was just
like
gone the next day i don't know why i
could see your brain powering down as
you drank it it's like
he had the audacity to be like this is
great sake it wasn't great it was
[ __ ] awful
i've had good sake that was just
slightly bearable and this [ __ ] was
awful
is it like just going off in your mouth
like it was something just going stale
and hit your body terrible be ashamed of
yourself yeah like the the
i've never had worse headaches in my
life after a night of just drinking sake
yeah
sake is by far the worst is up there
as well just above that is like all the
[ __ ] like spirits
they're really shitty tequila's what i
said tequila is the worst one yeah
i would say tequila and sambuca are like
on that level right
wait a minute i feel like like our
muslim fans that can't watch this
i wouldn't know i'll take your word for
it
because like tequila and sambuca for me
are like they're they're the student
shots they're they're what you get as a
student because
who drinks that all night [ __ ] the
psychopaths drink sambuca what even is
[ __ ]
exactly you don't know i don't even know
what's that it's that one drink that
your mate is like yeah let's get this
drink and then
you have it you're like like what is it
it's it's like a licorice shirt it's
[ __ ]
yeah it's it oh is it like like jaeger
oh i was about okay go go just the same
level
on the same level but like going above
that i would say is jaeger right because
they're all they're all like
they're all the shots where you know you
wake up and you
you can pinpoint the exact moment the
night went wrong
it was the exact moment someone ordered
like a round of jaeger shorts or around
sambuca shots or tequilas
for some reason melin [ __ ] loves
tequila
and i i will never understand that i
will literally never understand that
what about the taste it's good you don't
like the taste
there's other alcohol you can use a
concerning sentence
no we don't because we can't relate
because like it tastes like us
yeah and like the first i mean look the
only time where i was like okay tequila
is kind of fun it's like the first time
you do like a
you know like the with the whole salt
thing right yeah like that's like
because that's like
the whole
if you're like a student yeah which is
like when you start you know
trying all these drinks if you had some
kind of [ __ ] quick time event to it
drinking becomes like 10 times more fun
yeah you're a [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah
exactly
like there was a [ __ ] in in swansea when
i went to university there was this one
bar that would do these drinks with
sambuco where they would light it on
fire
yeah and then like put the like gas
chamber yeah that's what it's called
which is not a very flattering name it's
called a gas
chamber which is terrible yeah yeah and
so they would do it for like one pound
50 right which is like 2.50 i didn't
know it was legal in the uk
because i i don't know if it is but i
they served it because because the only
the only time i've been able to do that
is not in the uk but it's when we go on
like [ __ ] it might be illegal but you
know how the bars are in the uk
sometimes
yeah you know you know on the bars you
know how some of the student bars are it
feels like it's like world war three in
some of these parts yeah people are
throwing up everywhere they're serving
drinks people they shouldn't be
like yeah they would light the sambuca
on fire and put a gl wine glass over it
to extinguish the fire i've seen those
yeah yeah and then they would put the
wine glass on the table really quickly
and then you would chop the thing and
then you'd have to breathe in the fumes
yeah yeah yeah
wine glass yeah yeah and it would go
straight to your head yeah like you know
i've done those before okay
okay i've had sambuca yeah like you know
you know there are you know these like
you know these like student shops don't
do it because like even
even with like tequila right you uh you
lick the salt
um do the tequila and do the lime right
yeah somehow like [ __ ] students have
found a way to make this like even more
messed up because you talk about the
kamikaze shot
did you call it the kamikaze the suicide
shot yes suicide or kamikaze
okay so instead of okay so the normal
sounds like a jackass stunt it is it
[ __ ] is so the normal
order you go in is that you lick the
salt you do the tequila shot and then
you
suck on the seminal line right you know
it makes it bearable so okay how about
this
how about instead of licking the salt
you snort the snot
that sounds stupid and then you take the
shot and instead of sucking on the lime
you just
put it in your eyes yeah who the [ __ ]
thought of this so
i'm thinking about a new challenge it's
the [ __ ] yourself in public challenge
just shoot yourself on the train and
just see how long i had a friend of my
18th birthday who did
that three times why because because
they were playing darts and he was like
he was so [ __ ] cocky about it he was
like
i'll beat you like i practice every
[ __ ] day and i'm like
you're like seven shots in like you're
not going to [ __ ] beat me so you
watch them i totally understand people
like i don't want drinks
when you hear about this [ __ ] i'm like
why would you oh absolutely yeah
we don't need courage this is this has
always been a
[ __ ] step who did like vodka shots
through their eyeball
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
like what's wrong with people
what the [ __ ] is that you have a
perfectly functioning mouth just use it
like like i like for me i feel old
whenever you know
maybe i've always been old because like
any time i've heard like a story
story like that i'm just like who the
[ __ ] thinks this is cool
do you have brain damage it's like what
went on
what went wrong in your life to think
that doing a vodka shot in your eye was
badass right because this is why this is
the aspect i hated about being in
university is that like
they would be like yeah so you do the
vodka shot in your eye and i'm like why
and then they'd be like oh because it
gets you drunk quicker i'm like this
literally
takes five minutes yeah just drink it
and then i'm the [ __ ] weirdo out of
the group because i'm the one who
doesn't want to shut up yeah yeah
next thing you know he's like the
[ __ ] yeah next thing you know they'll
be like yeah i took like
some [ __ ] ethanol and i [ __ ] just
injected into my veins
it was [ __ ] rock and roll man that
was metal as [ __ ] and i'm just like i
can't
at what point do we acknowledge that
this is just stupid [ __ ] i don't want to
be someone who's done a shoei
a couple of times in their life like i
can't i can't really say anything
unfortunately
that's just that's probably the most
[ __ ] up one i've done yet
this episode of trash taste is sponsored
by harry's with harry's you don't have
to choose between a great shave and a
fair price
because you can get both i mean as you
know boys i took that shaving kit home
and uh
no joke it's the best shave i've had in
japan please send me more
raises harry please i legitimately am
running out please send me more
that's the realest promotion i'm not i'm
actually not joking
i really want more that's why harry's is
offering
our listeners a start set at harry's dot
com slash trash taste terry's delivers a
close comfortable shave at a fair price
still as low as two dollars a refill
that is [ __ ] amazing are designed to
stay sharp in a recent study
guys who shave four times a week said
their eighth shave was as smooth as
their first
here's how they've done it there's no
gimmicky features the harry's design
team combined a weighted ergonomic
handle with their signature blade
cartridge
it's a small simple razor designed to
deliver a close shave along all the
contours of your face plus harry stands
behind the quality of their blades so
much that they have a hundred percent
money-back guarantee on harrys.com so
what are you waiting for harris is
giving the best offer to the trash taste
listeners
right now new harry's customers can get
a starter set at harris.com
trash taste you'll get a five blade
razor a weighted ergonomic handle
foaming shave gel and a travel blade
cover that's a 13 value all for just
three dollars so there's never been a
better time to try
harry so go to harris.com trash taste to
redeem your offer today
back to the episode yeah i just feel
like you can feel okay i will tell you
when you know you've reached
the generation gap right it's that point
it's that point because i i remember
right when i thought yeah i'll always be
up for a tequila
or sambuca or jager bomb and then
somewhere along in life i reached like
mid-20s and i'm just like
maybe they're just better ways to get
drunk other than
doing these shots i don't know i don't
know you just kind of be like do i
do i wanna be drunk
i remember i used to think like i would
look at like all the dads at a pub right
yeah
i'm just like they're just sitting there
talking yeah
with a beer in their hand that doesn't
sound fun and now i'm just like i wish
for that more than anything right now
that's exactly right
exactly right um i remember i remember
thinking like when i was in university i
remember thinking i'm not i'm never
going to be like that i'm not i'mma
still be doing shots when i'm 50. let's
go i was like that was like 22. i just
gave up at like 21.
yeah i finished with university town to
be edged uh
to be an adult it's gonna be a boring
functioning adult it's terrible isn't it
yeah
um yeah i mean i remember recently i
went to my like some of my first wine
events
um went to a wine tasting event and
that's how you that's how you know
that's that's privilege that's how you
know you're like i've
i've reached that age when i'm just like
okay how about wine tasting it's like
yay
and uh yeah i remember taking conor to
one as well one time and
like i'm so this one time like the
people at this wine event
are exactly the people you expect to be
at this winery
everyone's like everyone's in like their
[ __ ] 40s or 50s everyone's like a
[ __ ] investment banker or something
you know something like with a monocle
and top hat
yeah yeah that was base that's basically
like the main guy running the event is
like this really old french dude
who you could see in like a monaco on
top hat right
and uh i remember so i was with sydney
yeah and so he was you know it's like a
very intimate event
so he would go around asking people
what's what they do and of course when
when they go
they go to us we mention youtuber and
like obviously people perk the [ __ ] up
right right and of course he goes to
sydney and asks what she does
and sydney very just very tastefully
says that you know she does
videos about anime and manga and
japanese culture and then he asks her
for her youtube channel
and she gives it to him and then he goes
oh let me just search this up and i've
never seen like the life flash before
someone's eyes as fast as i've seen
like cindy go no no no no no don't don't
do that don't do that
but the best the best part was so
um so so at this one event you know it's
uh it's it's a room full of people there
very
very prim and proper yeah it's it's a
very i
would say it is a very posh room yeah of
course and so
um we go up to have like i think like
our
third or fourth glass of wine that we're
trying and
so there's this word in french that
means cheers
you say in english as well though do you
say in the uk as well
okay so so what he uh so you know it's
it's that joke
that the guy makes every single [ __ ]
time because it's like it's like a very
obvious joke right
so he goes okay everyone everyone say
chinchin and then the entire room is
just silent
except i just here next to me sydney go
like it is not quiet at all she's burst
out
and everyone starts laughing i remember
just sitting there like
[ __ ] i'm with those guys
oh my god to be fair it is pretty funny
yeah that you came to like chinchin yeah
did you ever say that yeah in the uk
people always say chinchin like before
you down a pint or something like
chinchin
and you down it i've never heard that
before maybe it's like a northerner
thing i don't know people always said
that they say that in italy too don't
they
as well yeah i believe so maybe that's
where
oh god we didn't explain the joke if you
don't know uh chinchin
uh sounds like oh chinchin which means
penis yeah
so basically you're just saying peepee
yeah
really fancy hotel where like there's
literally security every like 10 meters
to check where you're in the right place
and then
each [ __ ] lap or what it was like
some fancy hotel or something
oh my god yeah i always feel really out
of place because
i'm just like a child so i'm like yeah
right i'm like i don't belong whenever i
go to like any fancy restaurant it
doesn't matter where it is
i'm just like i shouldn't be here yeah
yeah exactly the [ __ ] t-shirt
yeah i'm here to taste this place yeah i
just wanna i just wanted wine you know i
i felt
like every time i go to one of these
those events or especially like a
company party
yeah like i i i've never i never fail i
never feel more self-conscious than
whenever everyone around me is just
wearing suits and i'm just like
i had to bust out this like [ __ ]
wrinkly-ass like college shirt from like
the bottom of my wardrobe
i was just like oh [ __ ] it's great you
can go to these events and then people
will tell you about how rich their
parents are it's really fun it's really
really fun i love it it's great
it's just so depressing i won't [ __ ]
hear about how your dad owns ten
companies
you guys you guys should have like gone
in the [ __ ] jojo suits right you
should have just like fully committed
like
like proper like wear a monocle and like
a toddler
i don't think monocles have been in
fashion since the [ __ ] play you can
it you can bring it back
yeah bring it back i'll bring back
monica bring back the monocle
just cosplay the monopoly man that's
what i'm gonna do fake mustache and
everything just i want to get grey hair
so i can become the monopoly man
before it falls out and drink wine yeah
exactly oh my god
oh my god how the [ __ ] did we get on
this topic i don't know what we did we
didn't address the the wine to
the hangover tls by the way i'll just do
it for you right now is number one wine
is second beer's in the middle and then
all the other weird spirits are down
below
and then right at the bottom of sake
there you go boom so you say we did not
finish that tangent [ __ ] you yes
what's the next topic it wasn't an
extension
evian water spray
so yesterday i get there's a very
ominous message from maylin
all right okay when is mainly messages
not ominous
oh yeah okay so so i get this very
ominous message from alien just saying
hey tomorrow can i uh can i try
something on you
at the office this is never a good thing
what what the [ __ ] is going on here
right now
and she's just like yeah i have this
like ultrasound
thing that i want to put on your face or
something like it's for the baby is that
what it
is yeah i guess so mainly do you want to
explain what it was
it's like an ultrasound thing right no
it's like ultrasonic
warm vibration you're just putting
you're just putting buzz words together
yeah
the only time you hear ultrasonic is in
the sonic game
that is literally just a sponsorship
script but yeah it's got ultrasonic
buzzwords i have it right here it's a it
is an evian
facial sprain on your face no that's the
weight you'll find that's just that just
that's just to wet my face
where so she so how much does this cost
how much does this cost me that looks
like a vibration that it does look like
a vibrator that does
how much does this cost i don't know i
got for free
from who i don't know who's who's giving
out evian
costco costco i didn't even know they
had heavy in water spray before so yeah
so
um so for some reason i just agreed to
it and said yes
whatever do do whatever you need to do
mail in um and so
she puts this gel on my face yeah and
then starts rubbing
that first she sprays the evian
the evian facial spray which i think is
just
water that she's telling me it's
literally
i think she just sprayed warts every and
water on my face
put a gel in it and just did a [ __ ]
ultrasound on my face
and apparently we are never getting a
sponge
it's really just going back and forward
that's what it is
it's just it's literally that's all it's
doing how does that doing anything
maybe you
it felt like she was going to like she
was like [ __ ] doing ultrasound on my
face i want to start a business where
i just put my mouth against your cheek
and just scream and call it a therapy
the vibrations will heal any kind of
impurities
yeah so basically before we start
recording this episode
mailing was like i'm just going to do
half of god's face so that the boys can
see the
the magic and wonder of the before and
after um could not tell the difference
yeah
we're probably never going to get a
sponsor from evian but uh it looked the
[ __ ] same
like i don't know like can you tell the
difference in my face from my usual
the left side of his face was just a
little bit more moist than the other
side
that's all it was like i don't know what
i don't know what this is supposed to do
but
does it though or or are you just late
tonight it's for gullible people who
want to believe there's a solution for
everything
and sometimes you're just ugly that's
like that's like that's how it is like
that happens
i gotta deal with that no amount of
everyone water spray everything wrong
it's gonna [ __ ] fix my problems you
know what i mean
like it's just [ __ ] that's the thing
if this truly fixed your ugliness like
no one would be ugly because everyone
would just buy these
i will now end world ugliness
industry out of business everyone is
going to be a model after we
bring out water spray to the scene
there's so much stuff like that where
i'm like i'm sure
it works as like 0.1 but how much is it
like
a negligible amount where you're like is
it worth my time you know
how how how good does it have to be
where i have to sit there and rub my
face and spray avion on it you know what
i mean
how good do the results have to be you
know there are just some things where
it's like
i i get the intent as to why this was
invented yeah
but it's also like there are so many
other
alternatives that work just as well you
know probably a lot cheaper
yeah you know i mean like oh man look
like going back to the whole like
[ __ ]
amazon things you didn't you know you
need a thing right like that is a prime
example like that is just like
a bunch of people with like way too much
money who are just going on to amazon
buying all these [ __ ]
like things like i remember it's just
sad because i mean it's just like they
just
they feed off the insecurities that
people have like those like
like they have those uh weight loss
bracelets have you seen those
what apparently just a bracelet that has
like magnets in it or something
oh yeah it makes you lose weight and the
the before and after pictures are
[ __ ] egregious you'll be like the
most obese person yeah and then
apparently because of this one bracelet
which they probably can't even get on
their hand how exaggerated this
starts off as a ring yeah it's like
apparently
this one magically makes you extremely
hot it doesn't address the problem with
that if you go from like 500 pounds to
200 pounds
where's the skin gone yeah exactly what
actually sucks back in
like [ __ ] off what i love is when you
see the before and after pic and it's so
obviously not the same person yeah i
love it
it's just like someone so morbidly obese
that they think that because they now
have a six-pack he can't recognize that
it's just not the same
[ __ ] thing's totally off like the
belly button's totally different
like that there's no hair like one okay
so one thing
one thing i i always find funny is like
why always in the before
the before pick dude does like the
cameraman just say
look as depressed as you can yeah i just
just just like
it's like you're conscious like you're
you're smiling why are you smiling this
is the
before pic you know yeah yeah i mean in
the uk but they're just depressed in
both but i mean
it's just it's just it's like
subconscious right you see someone
smiling you you
your [ __ ] dumb monkey brains thing oh
good yeah yeah that's a that's a good
thing happened yeah good thing it could
happen thing here
i don't know i just i i get really sad
when i know that like clearly someone's
buying this stuff
and like the detox teases make you [ __ ]
yourself like it's just like
[ __ ] yourself of course you're gonna
lose weight because you're [ __ ] out
all the stool that you have in there
like
you know of course you're gonna lose
weight but it's just sad that people
like feel desperate enough and
they can't just like believe the fact
that it's like just eat less
yeah sometimes it's not that simple
though i know but that's the core of it
don't get cyberbully just turn off the
pc but like that it sucks because
just don't get hungry
but that's what it is the fundamental of
it is just like eat less
[ __ ] obviously there are exceptions and
then you know someone in the comments
being like i have ex con yeah okay
good but like a fundamental visit don't
buy this [ __ ] you know it's so yeah
but that's the thing it's like the
people who are buying into that kind of
stuff usually
or all yeah that's all it is like all
they need is just like a change of diet
or just something
so [ __ ] easy and yeah they're just
like
just don't be fast listen
listen i can vouch for the chicken and
broccoli diet
it works it works wonders the chicken
and broccoli diet is no joke i
it worked wonders for me you know a
simple payment of 6.99
trade offer trade offer you get chicken
and broccoli you lose weight it's simple
as that literally
i get 79.99 you get chicken and broccoli
i need
a chicken and broccoli company team up
with me i will show it dude
is there a chicken and broccoli there
actually is on ubereats around our area
there is a yeah yeah
actually i actually ordered another
[ __ ] one it's pretty [ __ ] good
there's literally a chicken and broccoli
chain that just delivers chicken
broccoli
this is how it works guys it's not fun
but weight loss isn't fun
it's like it doesn't need to be i i feel
like i mean
it's it's sad that you know some
sometimes in like self-improvement
a big factor in whether it's going to
succeed or not is if you're [ __ ]
enjoying yourself doing it yeah it's
it's unfortunate right but like
like like for me like for example going
to the gym
versus going to do like a sport or going
to do like a
like another active activity right
that's like doing that activity is way
more fun than spending
even like i could do three hours or
something of a sport
versus 30 minutes on the treadmill and i
choose like a three hour sport any time
but that's
but that's the thing like that's why i
think nintendo is like gigabrain when
they release ring fit
because that is literally the answer to
like you can lose weight and have fun
but
okay but this is the this is like i say
that having never played it
i play this has been sold out for a
while the
big problem that we have been like
believing for so long with weight loss
and this is like mainly
like i i know this is like [ __ ]
history literally it's like okay okay
disclaimer none of us have weight loss
experts don't take our advice
but it's like you know the big companies
like coke mcdonald's and all them
they're like yeah dude you can drink as
much coconut you can eat as much
mcdonald's as you want all you have to
do is just exercise
it's not the food it's exercise and it's
like exercise doesn't really do that
much for weight loss no
it's like but what weight loss what i
find personally what exercise does do
is the day when i exercise i am like
vigilant about what i'm eating
i'm like yeah no no carbs here like no
sugar
for me for me the day when i exercise
for some reason i just take care of
yourself yeah i know
i actually crave healthy food right i
don't know what it is about
yeah but like if i get if i go to the
gym for an hour that day that day
afterwards i'm just like
man i'm kind of just craving a chicken
breast yeah like [ __ ] this pizza
[ __ ] the curry or whatever but like when
i'm just like being a couch potato just
like sitting there you wanna you know
you're just like yeah yeah i feel like
[ __ ] so i kind of just feel like i'm
gonna eat [ __ ]
exercise yeah i feel like going to the
gym or like just exercising
in any way you can is like it's not so
much the act of losing it it's just like
the motivation yeah it's good for
obviously it helps you know general
fitness yeah yeah healthy and it's good
i'm not saying it's bad but like
i feel like we have definitely been like
it's not the cream
yeah we've also just been like told when
we were growing up right that if you
well if you eat 10 doughnuts just burn
off the calories and then boom no damage
that's not how it works 10 donuts 10
kilometers on the treadmill it's like
that's
not how it works though unfortunately
the trade agreement
you lose you lose uh you know you
receive 10 doughnuts i received 10
kilometers on the treadmill
like it sucks because it's like at the
end of the day it's it's you know
you could you could go in the gym and
distract yourself with it but it comes
to that moment when you're sitting on
the couch or you're wondering what to
eat and you've got to just
have the willpower to be like ah chicken
broccoli
fine fine yeah exactly you know it sucks
because it's like not fun it is all diet
i mean i i feel i feel like whenever
whenever you do any kind of
self-improvement activity it's not the
days where you feel good
that's gonna define if you basically
succeed it's the days where you feel bad
and you're able to push yourself through
and i say this being like i've had
plenty of times
when i have failed because i felt bad
and i just didn't
just not that's not not even the
motivation to push myself through i just
didn't have the self-discipline because
i feel like
self-discipline is way more important
than motivation because there are going
to be some days
where you are just not motivated and
it's those days where you can push
through
and i know plenty of people who have i'm
not one of them unfortunately
but it's like as well i found that like
when i was it's easy to like
eat really healthy for like two weeks i
know not easy but it's doable right yes
but then it's like all right well if you
just go right back to doing what you're
doing it's like well nothing's changed
well that's what the bounce back happens
well i mean that's why like i
i was just like what can i cut out that
it's like i can i can keep out like
forever so
i don't drink like soft drinks ever yeah
yeah i was like
the last like that [ __ ] yeah the last
like since juice probably the beginning
of quarantine
i've just made a conscious effort to not
drink any like fizzy drinks or anything
like that it's just cheese and [ __ ] like
that
tea and water it's tea water coffee is
all i'm [ __ ] drinking
yeah i mean i i i was lucky enough that
i just never have craved
like soda or anything in my life i've
just always grown up on drinking water
and
it's kind of made me realize that man
the habits you the habits you had as a
kid
really just like it's it's so much with
you yeah they stick with you it's so
much easier to learn a habit once
than to unlearn it and to learn
something else and i feel like
so much of my life like if i could like
if i had a time machine if i could
[ __ ] e-second myself back
into like a younger body there's so many
things i would do to be like okay you
learn this you learn this habit you
learn that habit so you don't have to
[ __ ] unlearn it
yeah and like and like have like a
[ __ ] year of your life being like
well i have this shitty habit that i
just had as a kid and
it's kind of [ __ ] me over and i want
to i want to try and do something else
but
god damn this pizza feels so [ __ ]
good right now
yeah it's like it's not even like i
don't even eat that [ __ ] anymore i most
certainly do
yeah i kind of like trying to balance it
out how much i do eat and uh yeah
yeah it's not like an everyday thing
right yeah i hate talking about the [ __ ]
online because everyone's just a [ __ ]
expert about it like in the comments no
doubt they'll be like 10 people would be
like i'm a nutritionist expert i'm here
to tell you that you're totally wrong
yeah
um because because everyone's got their
own opinion because er most people have
gone through it the experience have seen
what's worked for them and so yeah but
that's the thing it's what's worked for
them
right and that doesn't mean it works
fairly as long as you do it helpfully
you know you're not starving yourself
like you see some people like yeah i
lost 10 kilograms in a weekend it's like
that sounds like a terrible idea
what did you do that sounds like it must
have been some painful shits
yeah i mean i i feel like it's i think
one
important thing is that just because
something worked for someone doesn't
mean it
doesn't necessarily mean it's going to
happen with something else and it's it's
really like uh
what i found is it's really a trial and
you know what was it like
an hour trial and trial and error
you either lose weight or you die i used
to be like [ __ ] paranoid about like
well what's in this thing but i just
started thinking like if i just
eat a reasonable amount of things yeah
and exercise
i think i'll be all right yeah and that
kind of worked
i was like carbs i eat a lot of carbs
but like i just eat them within reason
like i
like my meals are never too big like i
feel like i ate a fair amount of food
like i
i feel like the one when i stopped
giving a [ __ ] about calories and stuff
like that and just thinking like
is this portion stupid yeah yeah is this
a whole large domino's pizza do i should
i eat this probably not
so i'm probably not gonna do it like but
i i feel like another thing
is that i don't know maybe it's just me
but i think i just enjoy food
too much all right what's the problem
that's that's the problem
it's not like i enjoy eating a lot of
food right but we talked about it
i do yeah i mean we talked about
enjoying the little things in life
every now and again and for me like my
day
is like 70 worse if i know i don't have
a good meal to look forward to
this is why i've just become an ubereat
slave at this point like i
every day i order from it now it's
terrible it's like but especially
because like japan is just you know the
land of [ __ ]
great food everywhere like food's become
a hobby at this point yeah
oh it is just like if i don't have a
good meal yeah that's like
i feel not i feel like i i feel like i
feel like my day is just like yeah
completely
i i feel unfulfilled yeah i go to sleep
and i'm just like i'm i'm sad i have
nightmares
i i had the worst ubereats order of my
life the other day it was it was
oh it was [ __ ] tragic it was like the
pictures looked amazing
the ratings were good you know and i was
a pork ball
okay and it looked very nice you know
and those oh this place only did pork
balls i thought great
they specialize in this one thing yeah
it's going to be [ __ ] magical
so i order it you know it takes a little
while not like crazy amount and then so
it gets here
and you know it's packaged amazingly it
looks like you know they've really cared
about like the packaging you know
give you an uh oh she bought it what's
your body yeah you know right now little
wet towel
like an actual like like a proper one
like the rolled up one yeah like real
thick ones and i was like
i was getting really excited for this
i'm like hell yeah okay they give their
own chopsticks a really nice chopsticks
as well
okay so i'm like i open this bad boy up
looks pretty good looks pretty good and
i'm like okay fantastic so i dig in
and i'm like oh no and i'm like okay
this is this this part of the rice is
kind of hard i was like
all right well maybe you know maybe just
this one section happens it clumps up
right
and so i hit another part and i'm like
oh no this part's hard too
and then i put it in another part and
it's hard and i go
and then maybe maybe she's needed a
little force maybe needs a little yeah
she'll pull it apart a little bit
and i picked this i picked this up with
like the whole bowl
and i and i i go to just pick what i
think is a small amount of rice
and the whole rice comes out i picked
the bowl up the whole bowl
like formed comes out yeah and i i no
joke this is where i started getting a
little angry
i started like i had my chopsticks like
this in my hand like a barbarian
stabbing it and like ripping it apart
and i couldn't rip it apart
so i shovel the meat on top to one side
and this is where i just get i was like
barbarian
i literally tried to grab it with my
hands to see if i could separate this
rice
i could not separate this rice with like
my full grit was like not even cooked or
what i don't know what the [ __ ] they did
to it and i i gave them one stars and i
was like literally
don't give me a break next time and uh
they said sorry the literal
they were like sorry you didn't like it
we'll improve next time give me a refund
i couldn't eat it i didn't get a [ __ ]
refund
and it ruined my whole night because it
was like 9 p.m and everywhere it closed
well i can't order anything down i'm
just gonna [ __ ] eat assembly or
something you gotta resort to [ __ ]
convenience store food yeah i had a
sandwich it was so depre you know how
depressing
it's depressing that's so depressing
sandwich at nine people one
sandwich as a dinner is there something
about it it's so depressing yeah i don't
know why
it is a ham sandwich for dinner it is
depressing
like like i i say having a meal to look
forward to i don't even mean like a
[ __ ]
five-star gourmet just like a good
filling meal like even like a knife
on a plate you know yeah just like a
decent thing on a plate i tear up you
know when i order a meal here and it's
just
yeah i i remember talking guys going
back to ubereats i remember there's this
thai place that i ordered
i ordered from whenever i'm like a
missing home or whatever yeah but
like we get i have no idea it's it's the
really fun oh i like really [ __ ] yeah
it's really crazy
i would have been like four times a week
yeah same thing it's so good
that's a that's a lot of that's a lot of
times i never get sick of pad thai yeah
but like i i get the craving
every now and again because i'm very
picky when it comes to thai food and
like my problem with this place is that
they they never [ __ ] make it spicy
enough of course that is true
as a thai person like i like every time
like every time i'm sure they [ __ ]
nobody might know me by name now because
every time i'm just like
spicy please spicy are you putting like
the comments yeah i put it in the
comments i'm like spicy fleas and it's
just
it's just never spicy enough like i
opened it and i could tell that they put
like a few
few chili flakes on there and it just
opens it doesn't even smell like no no i
i you know
you can take it back you can you can
tell when someone didn't try with the
spice right it's it's like
there's high chilies and then there's
like chili flakes and okay
so like last week there's one time i'm
just like let me try something different
so i
i asked for it spicy again right but i
don't i don't type it in japanese
i type it in thai oh yeah
so it's iphone thai okay and i remember
opening it i remember getting the same
takeaway box opening up this package and
this thing looked like it had been
cooked in like the flames of hell
[ __ ]
lucifer grilled this himself i open it
and like the chili to rice
like ratio was just like it was more
chili than rice
would you like rice on your chili can
you copy paste what you sent to him i
wanna i wanna see this i wanna try this
yeah sure i i've never been more happy
in my life when was it good
it was good okay okay i was like i
ordered the patron pal and like patriot
powers like
normally really really spicy in time
yeah and you know it's spicy when like
you have to like
you you you have trouble finding the
meat through the chili
right because it's it's like you got
you got you got the normal you got the
normal meat and then you've got like the
red
and green chili flakes or not just just
like raw chillies yeah i'm just like
you're my brother now now now now i know
you're a brother
just like we went to the um the indian
place near here
we do like indian food you know we do i
think we'd always ask for it really
spicy
like very spicy and it was quite spicy
but it wasn't that bad right
right i think uh i mean to you guys
level yeah because i mean i
you know even though i'm extremely white
i love spice that pretty much cripples
me yeah um
and uh yeah just to a standard person
like myself that shit's spicy enough
yeah but to these like [ __ ] spawns of
satan
because in japan when you tell them to
make it like 10 or max they just
they don't do it yeah and the first time
we went the first few times he
the person who was cooking it's always
the same guy he didn't actually make it
that spicy like it was just kind of like
oh
it was definitely japan standing yeah
like it was very it was like on the high
end for japan standard yeah i'd say yeah
yeah and then one time for some reason i
don't know why we went well he decided
this time he was like
fine i'm not playing he's like fine i'm
not playing anymore
and holy [ __ ] this is hard
to like yeah i was like i got like
halfway through this and i was like i'm
actually in like
severe pain yeah like this is actually
brutal i like
god couldn't finish it wow yeah
because it was i yeah i think it was the
one week where you had to go home early
yeah so
we were in this indian place yeah he was
not playing around
and i think i think i could see him like
in the corner of my eyes like he was
like watching us
because because we've been there so many
times we order the same
the same meal every time we order like
the most spicy option
and it's just like yeah we we it's spicy
but it's not like it's it's
like it's it's like it's a nice tingle
on your tongue what if he was like all
right the [ __ ] boy is gone
i'm gonna give you guys the real [ __ ]
now but it is it was by far the spiciest
meal i've had
in japan i could not finish it because
it got to the point where
it was just yeah well that's got numb
about it
like the last time it was just like i
was enjoyable about that though i don't
care i don't know what it is because
like the flavors get like enhanced
by like being just beautiful no i get
that to a certain extent
but the level you guys have it is just
like i don't even know what flavor is
anymore yeah i mean i feel like it
depends on the dish right because
i mean you can go to like coco ichiman
and um so
to explain have we have we talked about
that before glacier is like a japanese
curry
they have it in america oh yeah they do
yeah yeah and so you can go to this
curry chain in japan and they have like
a spice scale
from one to ten and like ten is the most
spiciest and i've had the ten before and
so is connor
and for me it was it was actually like
really spicy
but it just it felt like no however it
just felt like
you're adding spice for the sake of
adding spice right right
there are some dishes that i feel um
are designed to be spicy it's not like
flavor enhanced spice right yeah yeah
yeah it's just spice for the sake of
spicy like to me
like a mild curry a mild japanese curry
at least is
as good if not better than some of the
spicier versions but
there are some like thai dishes and
indian dishes and southeast asian dishes
where i feel
if you don't have enough spice to it
there's missing there's missing a
certain kick
yeah and also just a lot of endorphins
from the pain no i get nothing
i'm just like i'm constantly changing i
get i get the i get the fact of like you
know the spice enhances the flavor and
stuff like that because you know i've
had my fish over southeast asian food
and stuff like that which is quite spicy
and i'm just like oh this is hard to eat
but god damn like this probably tastes
way better than without the spice
and then there's your guys see the
reason why i got into spicy food
because again i have to bear my my
parents feel like paprika was spicy so
yeah when i was growing up i didn't
really eat spicy food but i just when i
started doing youtube i started doing
the like [ __ ] stupid pepper challenge
yeah yeah and then i've done it so many
times where i was like i could handle
the carolina reaper like
semi-comfortably right and i was like
[ __ ] spicy food isn't spicy anymore
because i've just been eating these
peppers raw [ __ ] youtube challenges
and twitch live streams
so i got to the point where i was like
oh god this is like really good now like
i really like it yeah like habaneros on
stuff is like perfect
no i see because like i love that when
we're talking about like kokoichi levels
of space right because that's the
easiest gauge
when you're in japan right it's like
what level of calculation can you do
you immediately know like i used i can
now do level three
right but before like couple of years
ago i couldn't even do level one
that was back from joe's wearing a
diaper that's when i was back when i was
wearing a diaper that's when i was a
true [ __ ]
like you need something you need at
least like a two yeah
right but i mean you guys can say that
because you're useless because you've
been eating it you know yeah but like
i mean i mean i feel like even some
foods where there's an option to pick a
spicy
version i don't always pick the spicy
version it very much depends on the dish
and whether it
complements it or not right right i mean
like you know now i could do a level
three and now
i understand like oh you know this is
actually so much better with spice yeah
to a certain degree but like
i had to kind of slowly trick my brain
into thinking that right because
if you had given me a level three spicy
kokuichi like two years ago
yeah i would have been like what is this
[ __ ] like this isn't enjoyable at all
like
i seek enjoyment out of my meal and this
is not enjoyable i mean i'm in severe
pain
but now i've like slowly started to
appreciate the pain
yeah right joey says getting a level
three yeah
i say like getting a level three i'm not
feeling those endorphins now that's like
honestly like to me
like that's [ __ ] painful but like
it's good painful
right and like now i'm finally starting
to understand i'm like oh okay
these like other friends i knew who
could eat like level seven and eights
who i just thought were like
absolutely [ __ ] maniacs just like the
noob anime character yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like i kind of get it now after
after my training arc i'm slowly
starting to get it
this episode of trash chase is sponsored
by crunchyroll this season crunchyroll
is saddle casting new seasons of
classics like my hero academia as well
as fresh titles including
to your eternity odd taxi and don't toy
with me miss nagatoro and now you can
binge
all of jiu-jitsu kaisen from last season
thank god what are you watching anime
zone
i'm actually watching everything you
mentioned because honestly
this this season [ __ ] slaps i could
recommend any of these but
if you want a shot in the dark watch to
your eternity try watching episode one
and not crying your ass off that sounds
amazing as always you get the biggest
catalogue of anime content with over 30
000 episodes available at any time in
subs and dubs and you can watch titles
for free on crunchyroll or try a 14-day
free trial of their premium membership
to skip the ads and access cybercasting
with japan follow the link on screen or
down below in that description
at www.crunchyroll.com trash taste so
what are you waiting for
start watching some anime and then you
can come talk about it on trash taste
right there there's a scene for your
eyes
thank you crunchyroll for sponsoring
this anime podcast back to the episode
well it's really weird right because
like you know obviously
you grew up in a thai household eating
spice food all your life right yeah
and you'd think i would be the same
because like my dad [ __ ] loves spicy
food like you know like the death source
that they sell here
my dad would just put that in meals
right like yeah but to me i was like why
are you putting cyanide in a perfectly
nice
why would you poison this meal like this
because then he would
[ __ ] serve it up to the family oh my
god and we would have to eat it that
reminds me my uh my older brother
he was growing uh carolina reapers yeah
and um why
yeah that's a good question because he
won he liked spicy food but yeah
um one time this was right before i
moved to japan
he he gave them to my parents and you
told them that they were like normal
peppers
oh wait why would you do that that is
true
they're like what happened that's a true
crime story yeah yeah so what happened
was
that they were like oh yeah they were
saying like oh brett's been growing some
uh
some peppers and he's he's given us some
right so i'm gonna put them in the stir
fry tonight and i think oh okay sure
i didn't know yeah that they were they
were carolina
or ghost peppers one of the other i mean
they're both [ __ ] they're both
[ __ ] hot yeah
bear am i my parents do believe that
paprika is spicy i'm not joking
they'll probably my dad watches the
podcast he'll be he'll be like you're
lying connor but
yeah um and so they made me it's the way
they did the stir fry is they make it
and they give it to me first and then
they
they make it for my dad and my mom makes
it for herself last and it's like this
is like five minutes in between
so i'm i'm eating this stir-fry and i'm
like
i'm getting kind of like i'm like
this kind of what this hurts and i'm
thinking like oh wow
my what purpose did you use
he's like oh ah this is your brother he
grew them and gave them to us and i'm
like
did he say what kind of peppers they
were so no no he just said he grew them
and i'm like
look a little kick to them
my parents didn't know they thought they
were like the like the numbers did your
parents eat them
yeah so so what happened next is that uh
you know i want them i was like i was
like i really think i'm like i'm like
bear in mind i'm like
i'm like really think that you should
like go easy on the peppers on yours if
you can like
get them out a little bit i think you
should do that like no no it's fine
we've had it before we've had these
peppers
pictures taken before disaster but at
that point i was like you know what
fine let's just see what happens let's
just see what happens
let's see how this unfolds i'm there
like literally like that that meme of
that kid at the
the vein on his forehead yeah just
eating these peppers trying to keep a
straight face like
i'm not my daddy he's he's about to eat
it he takes one spoonful and he's like
yeah wow that's really
that's really spicy
and he just like started like crying
i thought it was so funny and my mom
thought he was over exaggerating
so my mom was like i'll try it too oh my
god
and my mom starts doing the exact same
thing she starts [ __ ] her car
after like one bite they just couldn't
finish it they just started drinking
milk for like 20 minutes
they were just dying it was the funniest
[ __ ] i don't know
i mean if i was your parents i'd take
one look at you you'll be like oh he's
probably not making this [ __ ] up well
they
don't i thought they thought i was
exaggerating with how much i could feel
and i was texting my brother while after
i had a bite i was like what the [ __ ]
are these peppers these are
what peppers are these these and what
are these habaneros ghost peppers
carolina reaper they're like why would
you give them to my parents you know
they can't eat these
it's just bad isn't it
mom and dad your parents trust you they
they are so much i think from that point
onwards they just never accepted any
peppers
because i saw them and i thought oh god
they look like they look like ghost
peppers
some interesting shaped peppers look
like this they store the thin green ones
they look like the the big
plump like the shriveled like ones like
like satan's toe
yeah it looks like the spiciest thing
you've had uh
i'd probably say habanero
really yeah i mean i mean other than the
[ __ ] like
uh death source that like you know wait
have you ever eaten like a carolina
reaper or
like a like a ghost pepper why would i
do that oh my god we need to do that no
youtube challenge
why would i do that because it'd be fun
no it's no it won't for you
just build up your tolerance for you
guys it would be it's not that bad
people on youtube just
lit trial by fire
why did i teach them that phrase you
know people on youtube when i watched it
because i think i first saw rhett and
link do it yeah
yeah 2012 and they were like
it's not that bad it's just like it is
just discomfort it's yeah
it's why would i willingly put myself
into discomfort which makes great
content
yeah [ __ ] you got me there
who doesn't love killing themselves for
content like monster ramen wanker
but like why would that's way worse how
did you know how did you know i'll do
anything for you yeah
youtuber that's how youtube's mine's
works right
he got me there oh we're gonna film it
yeah
you gotta film it okay okay
the winner doesn't have to eat a uh
carolina reaper
dude that's going to be the hardest run
to a w in my existence yeah
right and then if it's one of us we have
to eat three
so what's the eating so i'm eating one
either way yeah of course
if like let's say you win me and gonna
have to eat three each yeah yeah but
that's not gonna do anything to you
no three three three will three will
help me out yeah
all right fine i'm i'm be high as [ __ ]
on those individuals like mesh with your
head it does it does like i remember
like the first time i like the first
time i had i probably had like a ghost
pepper or trinidad tobago like carolina
reaper the
the spice high i thought i'd heard about
it before yeah but i didn't realize it
was literally
like getting high yeah and you feel the
after effects
um for like hours afterwards because you
feel you feel this like
warm tingly glow yeah you just feel like
you did something nice and you're like
oh what's what's
like when the initial 20 minutes of pain
is over it's just like it's pretty nice
yeah i mean i i quite kind of looks very
uh unimpressed
unconvinced i mean i mean look it is
great i mean i've had the the death
source that they sell here which is
technically ghost pepper
sauce but like it's yeah but that's the
thing right it's like if we're talking
like just raw peppers like i've only
done habanero
yeah i mean i think the spiciest thing
like singular thing i've ever had
uh was back in university where it was
like it wasn't even like a ghost pepper
it was a ghost pepper
oh
exactly it was just like the pure
extract and i never like at this point
you know
i'd obviously like still grown up in
spicy food but i've nev i'd never had
like a ghost pepper or like an actual
one of the famous hot peppers that
people do youtube challenges over
uh about so um i remember this uh we
were drinking and my mate
he had this ghost pepper extract that he
was like daring people
carrying it around was it yeah yeah
because he's that [ __ ] yeah he
he he was like that guy he he was the
guy
you know you you know the guy who would
show people the two girls one cup
of videos we all had that one friend
like like the pain olympics
he was that friend so of course he had
this
he was recently yeah which i found
really funny what was that you only
found out what goats he was like
god didn't know what it was and if you
don't know what it is please don't
don't look it up it is someone's cheeks
being spread that's all you need to know
yeah so sorry so yeah so we had this um
so you had this ghost pepper extract
yeah and of course we were drinking as
you were at
university and it gotten to the point
where we
we were like tipsy enough to start you
know contemplating doing stupid [ __ ]
and of course you know you know you know
you know he's gonna commit credit card
forward yeah
you know he's an experienced friend
where he brings it out at exactly the
right time of the night where everyone's
everyone's intoxicated enough to like
think that it's a good idea
what a horrible friend yeah just waiting
till everyone is just
semi-stupid start feeding them poison
exactly so he brings out this extract
and he's like yo
i don't i dare anyone to [ __ ] do this
right and i see people doing it
and they're taking like the tiniest the
tiniest little
like drop yeah it's not even a drop it's
like less than a drop
right and i see people [ __ ] dying and
me um being like yo these are the giga
chad that i am
these these weak ass white guys don't
know their [ __ ] spice well
look look at all these guys right and so
and so it gets
my turn yeah i'm just like i'll i'll
show i'll show you how man does it so so
like there's certain favorites never
ever said that out loud
it's not a god phrase if there's one
thing i was confident
it's taking [ __ ] spice levels i don't
think you'd ever say and i quote let me
show you how a man
so like so like how the extract works is
like you have this like tiny little
spoon right yeah yeah yeah
that you can like put like one little
drip on so like i fill up the spoon and
i just [ __ ]
shove it in my mouth i i did not know
how spicy it was right right
and i never i never knew that i could
literally feel like i'd been shot in the
face
until i like it was just the biggest
instant regrets moment of my life like
normally
normally you see people taking like they
they take the carolina retail
repo they chew on it and there's like
this delay yeah right
no there was there was not that was not
a single delay in my mind yeah
my my body went into like fight or
flight mode immediately
like i was fine i took it and then like
five seconds later i swear i was in the
[ __ ] fetal position just like
ah oh god it hurts so much
i'm gonna try this now this sounds fun
it's it's it's
okay so what what do you want it's
interesting i'd like to try it
i will say i do not recommend it as
someone who can't handle my spice i
literally um it was nice taken don't
worry
what happened is i was i was out of
commission for the entire night right
because it was so spicy that it just
induced my gag reflex
so i was i was like i was on the toilet
i was like in the bathroom for like a
good three hours just like
gagging on on the toilet couldn't throw
up it was just like my gag reflex just
like
my body trying to throw up this thing
that was like one one little drop so
like there was nothing to throw up it
was like a drop
right but it it had induced this gag
reflex and i was on the toilet for about
three hours
and uh my you know my my university
mates being the good mates that they
were
they just just they just kind of went
clubbing and just left
you while you're on the toilet fantastic
mates well what a fantastic group of
mates well that's
i mean that's why i'm not friends with
them anymore
long story short i'm not in contact with
any of my unimates anymore but uh
i'm not in contact with many either yeah
they didn't poison me yeah exactly they
were nice to me
maybe what if it was all a ruse guard
where they all agreed to
take small amounts of this just so that
god would step up to the plate
let me show you yeah they were all like
oh we want to go clubbing but we don't
want to take guns
how can we how do we knock him out let's
get him out of commission yeah i know a
way i know a way that got to fall for it
that's about that i think that's what
they did maybe the spice challenge but
yeah that's uh
like i i i think i've read that no one
has ever died from spice before or like
you can go into shock though
yeah i think so yeah i i don't know i
don't know melon look it up has anyone
ever died from spice
yeah they can go so you can't die from
the chemical itself but you can die from
shock you can die from the pain
it induces yeah yeah yeah yeah you can
get like cardiac arrest
yeah yeah but it's always fun yeah
basically basically just don't just
don't do something
don't go into cardiac arrest
doctors hate
ghost pepper extract or any kind of
extract you know i wasn't going to
yeah and i think i'm still not going to
yeah i think that's
right i'm good
it was just like that scene from [ __ ]
pulp fiction right i just
i'm just passed down they have to forget
the [ __ ] needle and inject it
straight into my heart
oh my god oh god oh my god yeah so i'm
just gonna take it one step at a time
when it comes to spice like
i'm doing a pretty good job going up the
ladder i feel like yeah
just wondering about cpr i just like it
sorry because just
talking about moving my chest yeah i
feel like i'm too british to do cpr
i feel like i'd be like are you okay are
you okay is this is that too much it's
too much pressure
while i'm trying to save their life i'm
like what is that do you know do you
know how to do cpr yeah so i was a
lifeguard so we
had to do it oh yeah that's right yeah
luckily i always i always stop those
little [ __ ] before they
stop breathing did you did you ever have
to like do it no god no no you don't
you you'd know which kids were going to
drown right before they walked in
100 wow i wish i was joking how do you
know okay
i might as well just tell stories about
being lifeguards there's just so [ __ ]
so many yeah so
uh basically whilst i was working on
mcdonald's uh i want to be a lifeguard
because
well i could swim um good start i was a
really strong swimmer and
there was a course that i did that took
about a week um
and it was really really weird have to
do because i had to sacrifice a week of
school vacation
so i only had one week and i spent it
learning how to be a lifeguard i paid
like 400 bucks
and then i couldn't get a job for like a
year and a half because they were all
like yeah you don't have experience
cause i was like 17. right that catch
22. yeah right
no they didn't hire me but eventually um
because it paid really well at the time
mcdonald's paid me four pounds 10 an
hour which is this much in dollars and
uh the lifeguarding paid nine pounds 10
an hour oh wow which
at the time that was that's that's a
minted job bro
it was yeah but yes the thing was you
had to you had to have a week of
training you'd pay for it
that's a double shift at mcdonald's
right yeah and you know it was it's
on paper it looks like an easy ass job
because all you have to do is sit there
for 30 minutes and you get a 20 minute
break
then you sit there for 30 minutes you
have 20 minute break and that was it
basically
yeah um but when you're new they put you
on the at least minded they put me on
the shift
where it was uh kids birthday parties
and like because my mum swam at that
pool and they never put me on the shift
with the old people because all people
don't drown
old people no because they know their
limits yeah because they all go to the
swimming club
all the time and you know it's you know
they're not they're not going to and
apart from like freak accidents which
never happened and like people don't
drown in pools in the uk
the the year that i became a lifeguard
uh
zero people died from pools in the uk
that's good
so this doesn't happen why are you
laughing about it until i started the
job
but like okay so have you ever seen
those
floats that take up all the pool oh like
all the lanes and stuff or
the whole pool it's like a big
inflatable i've never seen it
i've seen them you've never seen these
you've seen these mainly
you ever seen these google it like it's
like a picture on screen literally
they're these
massive kind of like total wipeout s
courses right that you can inflate
and they take up the whole pool and if
you fall off you fall in the water oh
that's kind of funny
when i was a kid i i loved the kid
sounds like a trash day special waiting
to happen isn't it it's like yeah i
imagine like a bouncy house
on water that sounds fun as [ __ ] no dude
it is it's literally house imagine a
total wipeout obstacle course on water
dude it's bad it's dude when i was 12 i
love this [ __ ] can we do that
dude yeah
so like you could um basically for kids
birthday parties uh there'd be like a
five or six year old who would rent it
out now yeah
problem is with kids birthday parties is
that not every parent thinks that kids
need to be taught how to swim
right right i think because parents
forget that kids need to be taught how
to swim yeah yeah because you just take
it for granted
so what ends up happening is obviously
it's a birthday party everyone invites
their whole class
now half the kids in the class don't
know how to swim yeah but they still
are invited and go anyway yeah so you
know what
i'd be sitting there on my my thing and
i can tell immediately which one of
these kids can't swim yeah they look
like that jerry
what the hell yeah so they'd be like uh
it'd be like a
climbing thing and then you have to go
through pylons as a slide yeah
now you could tell immediately when you
look at these kids which couldn't swim
they just had a look in their eyes where
they were like [ __ ]
i've never been in this before what do i
do and that's a big
like thing of water because they're also
you know kids are like that thing where
like most kids
have like a built-in like danger system
yeah with their life
yeah like it's like heights right kids
know that they're scared of heights
kids know that water is like weird and
scary yeah and then the kids that run in
it right away
and normally like they can swim yeah
yeah yeah but so you'd be what you'd be
doing this thing right and there'd be
kids
and then you'd see this kid like you
just tell again you can tell he looks
he doesn't look confident right his
technique's poor you know
looking at the water really scared like
toe first right yeah
yeah so they climb on this thing and
bear in mind it starts at the shallow
end and it goes to the deep end
right where you get off right and then
we're talking like i don't know like
two meters deep yeah no no more than
that it's like three meters five meters
deep
i mean five minutes deep in the pool i
worked out that's pretty [ __ ] deep
for uh for a kid it's like
these kids these kids would just walk
right and then they'd get to the end of
this obstacle course
and you could see it that they were like
what do i do
everyone else is going down this slide
yeah and they're being you know they're
being egged on by their friends and they
just go down the slide
and they would just go down this is sync
they just sink they didn't come back
up they just wouldn't come back up wait
like two seconds
just to like make sure just to make sure
they don't come back up yeah
and then you have two choices you can
either jump in or you can get a really
long pole and like poke them with it
and hope they
well normally i just hope they're still
alive hello
so what i mean basically if a kid was
splashing around to be like ah you just
give him a pole
and he'll grab i'll like grab on to them
they'll grab on to anything
right but if you uh if they don't if
they don't swim
and they just sink which is like [ __ ]
[ __ ] go in so then i have to go in
and this should happen like three or
four times sometimes in like one session
[ __ ] hell because these kids are just
terrible and you i'd have to i'd like i
would
sometimes i would go and jump in i would
get a kid
yeah what are you doing stop don't go
near the deep end yeah
and then he would go and he would go
near it again and i feel i'd blow the
whistle back what are you doing
and then i look away for a second i look
back he's at the deep end again jumps in
drowns again
i have to go in and get him i tell his
parents off and his parents have a go at
me and complained to my manager saying
that
it's not my place to tell her what to
teach her kids and i'm like
it's not my place i should i could just
let your kid drown huh
see what happens then she went like full
carrying mode on me and try to get me
fired
because i bollocked her in front of her
like well because he saved their kid
because i went i i after i saved his kid
twice
i i hold his hand and i was like come
where's your mum show him where your mom
is
and then we went to his mum where's your
mom
what are you doing i was like why are
you letting this kid
into this pool without any armbands or
anything and she's like
i didn't have any floaties or anything
oh yeah why would that's why why didn't
they have armbands
right you know her reason was she was
like i don't want him to feel like he's
he's like you know the weird one the one
who can't swim and i'm like
but he is the one who can't see him
that's because he can't swim
he will [ __ ] drown do you understand
how this works
like i'm like did you ever teach him how
to swim no i'm like why are you letting
him do this this is really irresponsible
and then i just left and this was in
front of
all her friends because they had like a
viewing bathroom yeah and then she
complained saying i didn't need to do
that in front of all her friends it was
really inappropriate of me
i'm like i'm sorry but like how you saw
your kid drowned once and thought
i'll let him keep swimming yeah i'll let
him keep going that really pissed me off
i'm still really annoyed about that yeah
that's just funny i mean i just
that just sounds like bad parenting
that's terrible yeah
the people that stuff like they would
just let their kids listen unless the
parent was like [ __ ] i've been trying to
get rid of them
get ready next special we're [ __ ]
doing this doesn't this look amazing
dude and it was like it was a really
good job other than that like it's just
like
kids just like don't know how to swim
and you can tell a moment they can't
swim
yeah yeah um and uh yeah they would also
if you ever tried
sometimes if you'd um they taught you
and i never thought i'd have to use this
they teach you how to kick someone off
you if you're if they're like trying to
drag you down
oh well i'm gonna say if someone if
you're trying to save someone
right if i'm drowning you coming with me
because some people
when they think they're drowning they
panic and what they do is that they push
you down
yeah because they think i want to get up
yeah and you know it's not like a
selfish thing where they're like yeah
yeah i'm dying and you're dying with me
it's like
yeah literally it's like instincts kick
in for them and they think i'm gonna
i'm gonna push you down yeah to get up
so i can observe that yeah
what was the technique so what you do is
just like aim for the head
so if they're trying to like grab onto
you and push you down
you grab them by the arms and like like
so you
so let's say you're equal now in the
water we're both on top of the water
heads
you grab them and like you go down under
the water and you kick them up
and kick them off you right right right
right it's you push them away
and then you officially just grab them
by the face when you
i'm not i'm not kidding when you save
someone you're supposed to grab them by
the chin like this
and like pull them holy [ __ ] um or
you can there's some other ways but
that's the easiest because that way you
can kind of just do it like at your own
pace you can kind of
there's other ways like you can you can
grab them but that that's really awkward
uh
it depends like how big they are and if
you like if it's like a child like
sometimes grabbing them by the face
might be a bit much [ __ ] get over it
just imagine you like jewelry wielding
children
like grabbing it in the face
you know the worst thing was as well is
that when you this is the thing that
like you don't really think about is
that you don't bring spare uniforms yeah
that's not really your thing so if you
if you go in
um and you you save a kid and it's still
your shift you just go right back to the
chair
yeah yeah and you're soaking and you
know some people
they take the time like the first time i
did it i thought i i have to go in right
away i have to save their life
right away yeah and i wouldn't take my
shoes off or anything yeah but then i
realized all the people who are like
experienced they would just walk down
slowly they would just take off their
shoes
and socks because they knew they had
time and they knew like it's a pool they
know they're going to grab them right
away
so they're like i'm not getting my nike
air maxes where what the [ __ ] bro like
there's like a kid driving in the gym
they sit down like this right they see
them like because if they're flailing
you've got plenty of time yeah
so they would just like sit they'd like
walk down really slowly like this you
know and then they'd be like
okay take the watch off like this you
know like that
and then they would then they would go
in yeah it was really funny i just
thought it was really bizarre but then
they i was like why did you do that
isn't that like bad they're like no no
they're not going to drown yeah
they're not going to drown i know the
average time it takes yeah
well the moment again the money if
you're worried is if they don't come
back up that's when you have to like
immediately go
in yeah so that was all like that was
fine and like again this like never
happened ever this is only with little
kids because little kids are dumb
i mean i make out these stories to be a
lot more exciting than they are in
general the job was extremely boring
like it is
one of the hardest jobs to do just out
of sheer insanity like
you sit there for 30 minutes at a time
just watching people swim
yeah then you take a 20-minute break and
then you go back to it and this is like
for like six hours
just watching people swim and at first
it's such a weird thing to do because
i'm like
yo what if people get a problem with me
like staring at them while they're
swimming
you know like like because i'm like you
don't stare at people normally we got to
watch the pool right but
is it weird that i'm looking at people
like there's parents watching me what do
they think i'm looking at their kid too
much
but i'm just making sure that they're
not drowning okay it's not weird right
like it's like oh okay
about that he said this is the thing
these are the thoughts you have when
you're going insane sitting there for
six hours thinking like
is it weird is it weird that i'm looking
at everyone for like this long is it
going inside
like an existential crisis
i legitimately started like going insane
working there because i was like
you have to just think how long did you
do that for ah
god about just under a year and then i
went to
and then i moved away um but yeah i got
that job from doing a different job
which i talked about at different times
it's completely different yeah it was
really funny as well but like
lifeguarding in general is like super
boring but the pay was really good
because you have to get the
qualification
yeah and you have to be taught a lot of
stuff i mean yeah you're there to save
lives
yeah yeah yeah and the course is quite
hard like and you have to redo it every
year
and so i i can't be a lifeguard now
because i haven't got i didn't renew it
all right
so uh but for the one year it was yeah i
mean it was it was fine i mean the pay
the pay was insane like being 18 and
coming back
and i feel like learning the basic first
aid skills is really [ __ ] important
yeah it was really helpful because i
i was never taught it we don't get
taught in the uk yeah yeah we don't get
too so i don't know how to do cpr
i i
i do not know how to do the [ __ ]
heimlich maneuver are you going to learn
that as well yeah yeah we just have to
learn like all the basics
um all the basically probably i should
probably learn it now because
it's gonna be real awkward if i'm gonna
be like hold on let me just bring up
this youtube tutorial for a second
all right wait wait wait i got i got on
sponsored it's sponsored
i got an
a lot of aspects of the job were fun
yeah not many
like i had to like clean as well like
clean all the
toilets and showers which was like i
mean i didn't know i was going to do
that but
right glad you spent 400 bucks to clean
toilets
you know you you're there and when
you're wrapping up and there's no one
left in the pool you just start cleaning
because that's
what you're supposed to do um but yeah
and then sometimes
he uh i had to like because even though
i wasn't i wasn't teaching the kids but
for the kids who are like one year old
they're learning how to swim they had to
be someone in the water constantly with
them all right right and those kids just
[ __ ] like don't let go of you
and it's like no get off me little [ __ ]
it's like wrestlemania with like babies
it's like get off me
you're supposed to learn how to swim but
the moment they let go of the wall
they're like
and they've like they suddenly gained
the grip strength of like a grown man
it was just yeah i mean it was it was
just it's all right job really it was
just paid well
but the kids at the pool are scary just
just kids man kids [ __ ] suck
and if your kid can't swim teach them
how to swim yeah i mean like
when did you guys learn how to swim my
mom
my mom like swims competitively and
still does wow
okay yeah that's what i got right now so
yeah she still does uh like triathlons
and stuff
oh [ __ ] and she's like one of like
fastest women in her area and she's like
nearly like 55 or something like that
beautiful yeah so much more healthy than
me it's so sad
like when i go back home and she wants
to like go on a bike ride i'm like dying
and she's like just like breathing like
a casual 50k bike ride let's see that's
what she does she's like 50k
bike ride nothing did she watch the
cycling special i was like i thought i
raised you better
she's like pathetic no no really the
footage if you saw the raw footage
but yeah so my mum taught me like i like
i've always known how to swim i don't
remember not being
i i went to like a swimming school i
remember like swimming was part of my
curriculum
in like school oh really yeah yeah so we
had like a local
like swimming pool next like not next to
us but like really really close to our
school i remember
one like monday mornings was just
dedicated
to learning how to swim yeah i mean
i'm not a strong swimmer by any means
but i can
i still know the basics i still know how
to swim like to me it's it's still scary
um whenever i go out and i swim and i
can't feel the bottom i don't know
there's
there's like there's like the the fear
there's something so wholesome about
hearing that
why i don't know it just sounds like a
child problem
can't touch the floor i mean in the
swimming pool it's fine but like out
like out on out in the sea i remember
the first time no what's worse is when i
can actually feels like
something something yeah that's when i'm
scared
yeah i mean like if i don't know some
something like in in a pool completely
fine i didn't give a [ __ ] if i can't
feel the bottom
if i'm like i remember the first time
i've realized it when my when we were on
the beach it was
it was brighton beach's work so it
wasn't it wasn't exactly a [ __ ]
thrilling beach and i remember like my
mates just though we we're kind of just
like oh yeah let's go swim out
and uh swim out you know to where like
the [ __ ] boys are and i've never done
it before but i knew i'd swim and i
remember we got there
and i this is the first time in my life
that i had swam that far out
and this is the first time in my life
where i i got i got to this point
and i started kicking down and my whole
life experience had taught me
no matter how deep it is you can still
stand up
and so it was it was this it was this
realization where we get there and we
start flowing on the water and i'm just
like
where's the floor where's where's the
where's where's the ocean
was your six foot you just you take
floors for granted yeah
exactly right like i've never had a
swimming pool where like i couldn't like
stand up at least something like my
tiptoes yeah like i sink down a little
bit
and then you know i can still see like
the surface of the water i'm still in my
tiptoes i can reach the surface quite
easily
um so this was the first time where i
had i'd gone this far out and i had the
realization of
oh okay um there is no edges to this
pool that i can quickly grab onto
i've got a swim literally like all the
way back to the [ __ ] beach and
and the beach like you know that scene
in uh like movies where you know
the character gets vertigo where they
look down and like the ground just
suddenly like
zooms out that's exactly how i look
that's exactly what the beach looked
like when i turned around and it's just
like the beach just went
zoom like that and i was just like oh
[ __ ] that's why you don't really you
know you shouldn't be swimming if you're
getting even like one percent tired like
you should turn about
yeah i was already pretty tired you
should turn the [ __ ] off people drown
that's probably like the closest that
would come to drowning as well
people get tired and they swim out and
then they they're like they're tired by
the time they turn around
and they're [ __ ] it's so sad and and
yeah i i remember like
i remember turning around and being like
okay i've got to [ __ ] do this because
i
because one of the like the scariest my
life literally my life literally depends
on it and i was like
guys i think i think i've got to turn
back and uh i don't think i
kind of conveyed how [ __ ] terrified i
was to my mates
because they were like yeah we're just
gonna keep going without school with you
and i'm like
okay okay i'm gonna turn back now um
so yeah what a great group of friends
those are bad mates maybe
if they're letting you like do that dude
i mean i i i didn't have a good group of
mates when i was growing up if i heard
even like a breath from my friend that
sounded a little too heavy on my throat
yeah i'm like turn the [ __ ] around
get the [ __ ] back especially when you
get further out the waves get stronger
so
yeah exactly and then the currents come
in and that's when it gets really
[ __ ] scary
i mean i i can't think of anything more
depressing than just [ __ ] dying and
praying
you just at least if at least if i'm
gonna die on a beach let me down a good
beach like a nice beer
come to wales man we've got the finest
beaches man
my fondest memory as a kid because like
because australia every [ __ ] house
has like a pool in it because otherwise
you can't
survive the luxury yeah you can't
survive the summer otherwise
but um my fondest memory and i don't
know if this is like a collective like
memory for everyone
like every kid who like swam in a pool
but did you used to do this thing where
you would
go under the water and then you would
pretend to like walk
yeah i feel like you're in like on the
moon
of course that's the only memory i have
of being in a pool
even though i went to swimming school
for like seven
years to like learn how to like do all
these like different swimming things and
like all these fun activities and
whatnot
the only thing i remember is like yeah
i'm on the moon
what intelligent thoughts is joe yeah
the whole time you're talking about like
the pool that's in my head
that was just replaying over and over
again i'm like i want to go swim in a
pool again it's sad because it's so
[ __ ] hard to like
find a place to swim there's no pools
here it's like they thought they hate
swimming for some reason
unless you know you [ __ ] pay 150
bucks a month to go to a gym that
also just happens to have a pool in it
i'd pay to go to a gym with a pool in it
[ __ ]
i just want to go to like a pool i
haven't seen a pool anywhere
yeah honestly it's always weird to think
they just don't like pools
yes well i mean i don't know if how
statistically correct this
is but there's a lot of even adults in
japan that would just
never learn to swim yeah i mean like
if it wasn't kind of everywhere if it
wasn't part of my curriculum i probably
would not have learned how to swim
like i don't know where i would have
gotten the motivation to be like okay
i'm going to go out
and figure out how i'm going to [ __ ]
there's yeah let's play through waters
everywhere in the uk yeah because it's
in the public yeah
yeah exactly you pay like two pounds and
yeah because in australia it's almost
like sick second nature to be like oh
your kid is like
three to five years old well then we're
going to take you to swimming school
no question as someone who's a lifeguard
has there any like was it pretty
common for like you to find pieces of
[ __ ] in your pool just like
it happened like so from like a year
it was like code brown so it's like
that's what it was
you'd have to you'd have to empty
everyone has to get out you have to
close the pool
because you have to really you have to
re-sanitize it because it's like it's
like
yeah yeah because obviously there's tons
of piss in there but you can't see it
but then you see a giant mars bar
floating in there
you gotta you gotta fish you gotta fish
it out and then you gotta kick everyone
out same if like someone throws up
i think more people threw up than
throwing up in a pool oh i guess from
drinking all the pool water maybe people
some kids are stupid they they would
like some of them would drink the pool
water yeah yeah
some of them would just eat a lot and
they'd like jump around and then swim a
bunch get really exhausted and then they
would
yeah yeah how long would it take to
[ __ ] sanitize the pool i don't know
we had like a roomba
that did it there's like a roomba that
went around like the bottom and there's
oh yeah like the little yeah we used to
have these yeah we could go around
and it would clean it but the water is
like never like emptied
yeah it's um it's just like salted
yeah yeah and they they could do a
chlorine test every like two hours
yeah make sure the chlorine levels are
okay but i i never did that i wasn't
allowed to they were like we don't trust
you with the calling
with the chlorine connor get out of it
no i mean i was i was never like a
manager there so i just i was just like
there
just because i i i remember still having
like [ __ ] vivid memories as a
when i was like learning how to swim
just like finding a [ __ ]
in in like the swimming pool right it
happened like twice i think
yeah because like we would never float
it was
it would always be at the bottom yeah
and like as a as a kid i was just like
you because i was always been
short-sighted i was always short-sighted
right
in my entire life and i didn't know this
until i was like maybe 10 years old that
i was
oh short-sighted god actually i remember
i remember
i remember as a kid right i would be
looking sitting really close to the tv
because like like when playing games or
whatever my mom just like stopped
sitting so close to the tv
and and i was like but i can't see it
and my mom's just like look harder
you're not you're not looking hard
enough get better eyes
and then it was only when it was only
when um it's only when we realized
that we know when i was in the audience
but i was just i i was just born with
bad eyesight you know unfortunately
so as a kid i didn't have glasses at the
time so
i would be swimming in the pool and i
would see this like little
i remember seeing this like little black
[ __ ] thing like
in the corner of this pool right and you
do and it was it was it was [ __ ]
blurry as [ __ ] right so i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is this black thing no
in this in the corner before i've
noticed
and so like out of you know they say
curiosity killed the cats
um so uh me being the curious little you
know
[ __ ] six year old i was or whatever
like i swim closer and closer to it
right
i'm looking back i i can hear the
[ __ ] jaws music just
playing in the background i'm like
done and so like i'm it's i start
swimming closer and closer to it and it
starts like
slowly slowly enhancing slowly slowly
coming into focus right and it starts
like okay so
it becomes this blurry mess and it
becomes
this cylinder shaped thing and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] is a cylinder shaped
thing doing
in the swimming pool right right and so
i get closer and i get closer and then
i'm literally like
so the shit's there right and and so i
literally was just like
and then i like when it when it like
because because like when it fully came
into focus
obviously when i'm this obviously when
i'm this close i can see the entire
[ __ ] detail
you're like two inches away from a piece
of [ __ ] yeah i can like you know you can
see the [ __ ] texture of the [ __ ]
right now like that's how detail there
was in my mind i let out the biggest
underwater scream i had of my [ __ ]
life
it was literally like a [ __ ] horror
movie when i'm just like
you know you know what the
the that's such a good story
the weirdest time that there was a [ __ ]
in the pool and this happened only twice
while i was there
and i was just completely confused how
there was a [ __ ] in the pool
yeah and we i still to this day cannot
figure out what happened
so i'd love some scientists uh in the
chat to explain what the [ __ ] happened
yeah
so they would do this thing at my pool
where they would have like
uh like how to learn how to kayak so
they would let like
uh like six like in the pool yeah they
would let people they would put six
kayaks in the pool and just let people
kayak around it
and i don't know how this happened but
after the kayak has left
there was a [ __ ] in the pool now they're
in kayaks
how do they get in the pool did some of
them just window out like put their butt
out
and just like squeeze it out how does
that happen how does that [ __ ] in the
pool after kayaks
does anyone have an idea of how this
happened i because we were all
completely confused and
luckily it was the end of the day but we
were just like how is this [ __ ] in the
pool
you're like looking back on like the
security footage cameras like we gotta
find the exact moment
came out we wish we had security footage
to [ __ ] analyze
if someone's done a cheeky [ __ ] that
they bring it and drop it in like
did they do it in the kayak and then
just [ __ ] scooch it in like what
happened
i should stay i i wake up in cold sweat
wondering how did that [ __ ] go wait were
there like
adults in the kayak no it was just like
15 14
13 year olds what 15 14 year old is like
i'm a [ __ ] in this pool kids are [ __ ]
weird man kids kids are weird but you
think like after like the age of 12 you
think like
there is a there is like a mental like
stop in my brain to be like
no pooping in the pool is bad some kids
are so dirty though i don't give a [ __ ]
gross yeah i mean i mean like even just
pissing in the pool right
i've done
it's something that we don't like like
to admit but of course everyone's done
it everyone does it right
right now it's the own fart biggest
you know you just get in the pool and
you realize [ __ ] i need a piss yeah i
just got in yeah i don't want to get out
i'm not getting hurt
i'm gonna piss everyone else is doing it
we're all just drinking each other's
piss anyway
this pool is massive oh no it's got
chlorine in it for a reason
wave it around a bit whatever it is what
what
that that's a [ __ ] pool melon public
pool melane
public pool is basically pissed why do
you think they put this
michael phelps says he pisses in the
pool if michael phelps can piss in the
pool
i can piss him yeah it propels him right
it's like an extra engine
he is the gold standard of swimmers if
he can piss in the pool
as far as i'm concerned i can piss him
it's like a jet propeller right it's
just like through here you know i i'm
not [ __ ] in the pool
you know big difference between pissing
and shooting
one of them evacuates the pool the other
one is the thing everything everyone
else is doing it's not a problem
i will not have to justify pissing and
okay i don't just get in every pool and
i'm like
i'm all i'm saying is that you know if
you've got a wetsuit on or something
it's like i'm
you know what i'm going to make myself
warm you know who else pisses in the
pool though
our patrons yeah they do yes all of
these people
these people they definitely piss on the
poor look at all these lovely people
right
here look at all these lovely pool
pieces right here
but if you've gone from [ __ ] spicy
food to [ __ ] pissing in the pool
welcome to an episode of sounds episode
to me but hey if you'd like to join the
patreon then make sure you go to
patreon.com
trash taste also yeah also follow us on
twitter send us your means on the
subreddit and if you hate our faces
listen to us on spotify
yeah and i think that's everything for
today right lads we've had a pretty
indeed pretty colorful episode today um
i don't even remember what we [ __ ]
talked about
what the [ __ ] wrong with us i'm glad
we ended it on what we usually
understand
which is poo poo pee pee story poo poo
pee pee pee pee
story exactly if you didn't know we have
trash taste after dark where we
occasionally stream live
on twitch and the vods get uploaded to
that youtube channel
so yeah so if you'd like to check out
our twitch and also after that channel
check out the description below thank
you so much for watching gamers yeah
we will see you guys next time
you